[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour le temps fort de la
semaine au sénat les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement ça commence
dans une heure à 15 heures précises une
heure et 16 questions pour interpeller
le gouvernement
mais avant cela notre grand débat sera
consacré au parc national financiers
l'institution judiciaire créé à la suite
de la sphère cahuzac est dans la
tourmente
les propos des lianes houlette l'ex-chef
du pnf qui a évoqué des pressions
hiérarchiques dans la sphère fillon ont
mis le feu aux poudres
la droite réclament sa suppression et
nicole belloubet on l'apprend l'instant
diligente une inspection sur les
investigations du bnf dans la sphère des
écoutes de l'avocat de nicolas sarkozy
la dette qu vider ses 136 milliards
d'euros doivent-ils être pris en charge
par la sécurité sociale
c'est l'objet d'un projet de loi discuté
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle et le
thème de notre face à face à 14h30
on reviendra aussi sur la défense
d'agnès busin qui nie tout le monde
d'anticipation dans la gestion de la
crise mais aussi on parlera du ségur de
la santé enfin dans une heure les
questions d'actu on va faire vivre tout
ça avec alexandre poussard alexandre
pouchard qui nous attend dans la salle
des conférences
alexandre alors qu'est-ce qui est au
menu bonjour tam et bien aujourd'hui
les sénateurs vont revenir sur les
propositions de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat des propositions qui ont
été retenues pour leur majorité par
emmanuel macron le président de la
république est d'ailleurs plutôt ouvert
à un référendum pour inscrire dans la
constitution la protection de
l'environnement un projet de référendum
qui n'a pas vraiment convaincu les
sénateurs et on va donc écouter leurs
questions toujours sur l'écologie les
sénateurs vont interroger le
gouvernement sur la fermeture définitive
de la centrale nucléaire de fessenheim
une fermeture qui pourrait augmenter nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et si
oui eh bien ce serait une mauvaise
nouvelle pour le climat et enfin il ya
une question qui va retenir toute
l'attention ici au sénat elle concerne
le parquet national financiers et
l'instrumentalisation politique de la
justice dans les affaires visant
françois fillon et nicolas sarkozy est
d'ailleurs cette question elle sera
posée par le sénateur les républicains
pierre charon un proche de nicolas
sarkozy
alors que la ministre de la justice
vient de diligenter une enquête de
l'inspection générale de la justice sur
le rôle du bnf dans les écoutes de
l'avocat de nicolas sarkozy
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
précisions et ce menu alléchant on
retrouve tout à l'heure et n'hésitez pas
à commenter cette émission avec le
hashtag que âgées on en parlait à
l'instant ça va être notre débat du jour
les magistrats du parquet national
financiers chargée d'enquêter sur les
affaires de corruption de fraude fiscale
sont très attaquées actuellement la
droite demande la suppression de cette
institution judiciaire
ce sont les propos des lianes houlette
évoquant des pressions hiérarchiques
dans la sphère fillon qui ont mis le feu
aux poudres alors qu'est ce qui est
reproché au parquet national financé
quel est son bilan et plus globalement
faut-il revoir le statut du parquet en
france on va parler de tout ça avec nos
invités
mais d'abord retour au contact le
parquet national financier dans la
tourmente
alizée boissin elle est celle par qui le
scandale est arrivé
il y as noulette ancien procureur de la
république financière n'y est pas allé
de main morte devant la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur l'indépendance
du pouvoir judiciaire dans la sphère
fillon la procureur général de paris lui
aurait mis la pression pour accélérer
les enquêtes et imposer des choix
procédural demande date d'audition aux
demandes de précisions sur les
perquisitions en cours
demanda de précisions sur les
réquisitions supplétives bon donc oui on
ne peut que se poser des questions la
décision est rôle très étroit c'est un
contrôle très étroit des soupçons de
pressions hiérarchiques
mais le pnf est aussi décrié pour ses
méthodes c'est le cas pour la faire
sarkozy le pnf aurait tenter de
démasquer la taupe ayant informé
l'ancien président qu'il était sur
écoute
l'institution aurait alors décortiquer
les fameuses fadettes ses factures
téléphoniques et d'une dizaine de ténor
du barreau la procédure secrète a duré
six ans le chef du parquet financier
confirme l'existence de cette enquête
mais défend l'impartialité de
l'institution à aucun moment ces
personnels magistrats comme policiers ne
sont si vous me permettez l'expression
sorti des coups
des affaires politiques qui font hurler
la droite ce député demande la
suppression du parquet national
financiers de façon générale le pnf
s'apparente de plus en plus à une
juridiction d'exception
cela n'est pas sain créé pour les
affaires financières complexes
il s'est transformé en lieu de tract
politique avec une prédilection et une
célérité particulière pour les opposants
et une lenteur et une clémence constante
pour les amis du pouvoir actuel et passé
en six ans d'existence le pnf a traité
plus de 1000 dossiers et c'est le sujet
de notre premier grand débat sur ce
plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
katia dubreuil bonjour bonjour vous êtes
présidente du syndicat national de la
magistrature merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous également avec nous jean pierre
sueur bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste du loiret vice président de
la commission des lois également avec
nous patrick maisonneuve
bonjour bonjour avocat vous êtes l'un
des ténors du barreau de paris merci
beaucoup d'être sur ce plateau et enfin
à distance j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
thomas clay professeur de droit à la
sorbonne universités paris 1
vous êtes également avocat et vous avez
écrit une tribune dans le monde qui
dresse un bilan positif de l'activité du
parquet national financier patrick
maisonneuve première question pour vous
le parquet national est aujourd'hui mise
en cause qui a mis le feu aux poudres ce
sont les propos des lianes houlette qui
a parlé de pressions hiérarchiques
la semaine dernière devant les députés
est ce que pour vous ça pose problème
alors écoutez en ce qui concerne les
propos de madame houlette halal a parlé
de d'information qui lui était demandé
par le par le procureur général auprès
de la procureure
général des informations qui lui aurait
été demandée avec avec insistance mais
ces informations ils sont prêts elles
sont prévues dans les textes
elle a précisé qu'elle n'avait pas reçu
d'instructions de qui que ce soit ce qui
me pose plus de problèmes en temps en
temps et avocats se sont dits viendra
peut-être faire des sons les l affaire
des fadettes par les écoutes affaire des
fadettes les relevés de fadettes est
géolocalisé pour certains des avocats ça
c'est un cetain c'est un sujet qui nous
préoccupe particulièrement on va en
parler mais d'abord un mot sur les
propos des lianes houlette et qui eux
parlent effectivement est bien de ces
pressions qu'elle a dit ressentir mais
l'a bien dit pression hiérarchique un
pas pression politique jean pierre sueur
j'ai le sentiment que dans un premier
temps on a pu comprendre ce qu'elle a
dit comme des pressions politiques oui
puis elle a précisé que c'était la
procureur général de paris qui avait
demandé des explications
ce qu'elle peut faire en effet comme
maître maisonneuve l'a dit maintenant
vous savez moi j'ai une position très
claire très simple il faut que le
parquet soit indépendante
on va y venir exécutif qui viennent
révision constater et dori et j'y suis
très attaché et je trouve que c'est un
grand échec qu'on ne l'ait pas encore
fait
on va élargir à ce sujet mais d'abord
restons et bien sûr les propos des
lianes ou lect et du fait que et bien la
droite aujourd'hui et d'en tirer
immédiatement des conséquences et juge
qu'il ya donc eu une pression non
seulement hiérarchique mais pour la
droite c'est une pression politique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez katia
dubreuil oui mais la difficulté si c'est
que et ian white a décrit effectivement
des remontées d'informations qui sont
parfaitement légales elles sont prévues
par le code de procédure pénale que ce
soit du parquet au parquet général ou du
parquet général à la ministre ou au
ministre donc le problème c'est que ces
remontées d'informations quand on sait
que le pouvoir exécutif a en main des
éléments sur les affaires en cours et
par ailleurs nomme les magistrats du
parquet forcément ça sème le doute dans
l'esprit du citoyen et donc la confiance
dans la justice et d'ébranler c'est la
raison pour laquelle monde
si nous aussi cette réforme constitue la
halle mais ce qu'elle a décrit que sur
lesquels les responsables politiques ont
crié au scandale c'est l'application du
codé pression pénale que ses
responsables politiques n'ont jamais
voulu modifier jusqu'ici que ses
voulu modifier c'est aussi votre
argument thomas clay effectivement pour
vous ce parc national financier bas on
le on le critique
aujourd'hui quand on est attaqué mais on
n'a pas forcément voulu et bien changé
son statut lui et donner plus
d'indépendance quand on est au pouvoir
on est en train de se faire manipuler
par ceux qui ont intérêt à la
disparition du parc national financiers
et ceux qui ont intérêt à la disparition
du pns sont ceux qui sont poursuivis par
le pns donc plutôt que d'essayer de se
défendre sur le fond du dossier
ils s'en prennent à leurs juges le pnl
vous l'avez rappelé dans vos titres
c'est plus de 1000 dossiers depuis sa
création en 1993 donc très très peu de
dossiers concernent des affaires
politiques des literies sont avant tout
les affaires financières complexes
élaboré mondialisée des dossiers comme
google des dossiers comme hsbc des
dossiers comme ubs et il est aussi comme
airbus ou le pnf a comme obtenu 2
milliards d'euros de paiements de la
part d'airbus qui a reconnu sa
culpabilité en janvier 2020 que pnf est
un fantastique instruments de réponse et
de réplique à la la délinquance
financière astucieuse et mondialisé et
parfois elle croit certains dossiers
politiques et quand je vois un député
comme eric ciotti demander la
disparition du bnf je trouve ça indigne
indigne à moins qu'il soit mandaté par
ses coreligionnaires pour demander ce
type de de disparition mais il faut bien
savoir que voilà le pnf fonctionne et
que ce n'est pas du tout du tout du tout
une police paul une justice politique
comme on pourrait croire qu'après ce
prix-là questions qui ont été posées
j'arrête là par vos invités sur le
plateau c'est à dire la question de
l'indépendance du parquet général
on va en parler mais vous le dit
effectivement le pnf fait actuellement
l'objet bien d'une critique globale un
de la droite on a parlé d' eric ciotti
qui demandent sa suppression écouter
également le président du
groupe l air au sénat bruno retailleau
qui était l invité de notre émission
audition publique ce lundi
il ya deux hypothèses parce que soit il
ya une hypothèse politique soit il ya
une autre hypothèse c'est que il ya une
partie et je ne veux pas généraliser de
la magistrature qui se considèrent
investi d'une mission et qu'il devrait
peut-être un ressentiment vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique
moi je ne sais pas mais en tout cas il
ya une forme de politisation qui est
inquiétante
il ya un doute qui est désormais jetés
sur la justice il ya un doute sur la
justice estime bruno retailleau
ce qui trouble notamment aussi les
détracteurs c'est la rapidité de la
justice sur cette affaire fillon on va
voir quelques dates alors il ya le fait
que le juge serge tournaire et été
désigné ensuite je vous donne quelques
dates alors le 25 janvier 2017
il ya les révélations du canard enchaîné
l'ouverture le même jour de l' enquête
préliminaire du parquet national
financiers le 24 février l'ouverture de
l'information judiciaire le 15 mars 2017
et bien françois fillon est convoqué en
vue de sa mise en examen patrick
maisonneuve on reproche c'est voir
plutôt le contraire à la justice d'aller
trop lentement et on lui reprocha
lenteur
général est anormal mais ceci étant dit
mon nom parce que pas moi
personnellement je ne trouve pas pour
une simple raison le juge tournaire il
n'est pas désigné par le parquet n'est
pas désignée par le garde des sceaux
c'est le président du tribunal de grande
instance qui qui procède aux
désignations sein c'est la preuve la
première chose
et en ce qui concerne la sphère fillon
elle même c'est pas une affaire qui
comporte des complexes complexité majeur
il n'y a pas de commission rogatoire
internationale
il n'ya pas d'investigation tous azimuts
il faut mener cette lutte va durer des
mois
je dirais qu'à la suite de l' enquête
préliminaire qui était intervenu les
juges d'instruction avaient hérité d'un
dossier qui était assez complet
finalement on n'est pas dans ce
qu'évoquait totomat est tout à l'heure
dé la grande délinquance financière avec
des répercussions internationales avec
des recherches fouillées qui va
intervenir notamment monsieur sur des
cantons que alors on peut toujours
penser on peut jouer tillon turquie une
suspicion alors une suspicion parce
qu'on dit ont fait traîner et donc si on
fait traîner
c'était une arrière pensée politique si
on ne fait pas traîner sur bath il y
aura aussi les narines arrière pensées
politiques
encore une fois vous savez moi les
magistrats instructeurs en question ce
ne sont pas des gens qui sont
particulièrement tendre les juges que
quand elle en a parlé dans ces dans
cette procédure
mais en tous les cas ce que je sais
c'est qu'on ne va pas donné
d'instructions ces magistrats se tairont
pas leurs commandes et quoi que ce soit
le tribunal de paris a rendu une
décision il ya un appel sur cette
décision jusqu'à la fin il ya une
présomption d'innocence bien bien
évidemment mais encore une fois des
trois juges qui rendent leur décision du
tribunal de paris
ce ne sont pas des juges qui sont aux
ordres du pouvoir exécutif en prêt je
crois qu'il faut un peu arrêter avec ça
jean-pierre ce faire il ya un autre
problème prime que vous sauviez tout à
l'heure le fait que le parquet national
financiers et demandé à éplucher les
factures téléphoniques détaillées les
fadettes d'avocats de magistrats est ce
là le l'objectif c'était de trouver la
taupe qui a pu informer thierry herzog
et nicolas sarkozy qu'ils étaient sur
écoute dans une affaire de corruption
finalement la sphère fillon ne posent
pas forcément problème est-ce que ça
pour vous quand même c'est un sujet ça
pose problème
oui
le code de procédure pénale fait sans
doute une distinction entre les écouter
les fadettes
mais pour moi très franchement c'est
profondément anormal que l'on une
espionne un avocat lorsqu'il exerce sa
mission d'avocats c'est à dire que on
doit pouvoir tout dire à son avocat tout
oui et on a le droit
quand on dit quelque chose à son avocat
à qui on fait confiance de n'être écouté
par personne et l'avocat lorsqu'il fait
son métier de défenseur il ne doit pas
être écoutés par quiconque voilà ma
position et je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé mais en tout cas puisque vous me
demander ma position je vous la donne
katia dubreuil l'avocat eric
dupond-moretti dont les fadettes ont été
décortiquées sur plusieurs jours a
annoncé d'ailleurs porté plainte et lui
va plus loin encore dans sa critique il
parle d'une clique de juges qui
s'autorise tout alors bon il ya
l'émotion aussi d'eric dupond-moretti sa
verve
mais est-ce qu'il ya pas eu un problème
tout de même dans les bars de
décorticage de fadettes
oui enfin il ya sa verve mais c'est vrai
que les attaques
en tout cas la façon dont les avocats en
tout cas ses avocats qui sont visés et
les organisations professionnelles
réagissent est effectivement assez
virulente
il faut quand même rappeler que
effectivement aller chez la protection
je pense que on pourrait être un peu
plus sur l'examen des principes et un
peu moins sur la virulence parce que en
plus avec ce bruit médiatique justement
actuel autour du pmf on n'a pas
forcément on pourrait rester calmes et
regarder les choses objectivement le
code de procédure pénal ne prévoit rien
en ce qui concerne les fadettes des
avocats ni les bornes h
donc on a parlé de décision illégale
scandaleusement illégal etc
on a entendu parler de ça ça reste chez
les gens les citoyens qui nous écoute
entendent que le parquet national
financé a fait quelque chose d'illégal
ce n'est pas le cas après bien sûr que
là la question de la proportionnalité
d'instigation sur des avocats alors
qu'il ya ce principe très important du
secret professionnel de l'avocat qui
protège principalement d'ailleurs les
clients de l'avocat
c'est une question qui doit être posée
et s'il ya des réformes éventuellement
du texte à faire pour introduire une
protection comme ça existe pour les
écoutes
effectivement c'est une bonne idée et on
peut aussi discuter effectivement en
l'espèce de la proportionnalité de
l'utilisation de ces investigations dans
l'enquêté en question mais il me semble
quand même que quand on se prononcent à
partir d'éléments épars qui sont dans la
presse sans avoir tous les éléments il
faut rester prudent alors quelques
éléments sur les réactions l'actuel chef
du parquet national financier a lui
estimé qu il n'y a rien à dire sur l'
affaire des fadettes
on peut regarder aussi bien la réaction
de nicolas sarkozy dans un tweet
l'ancien chef de l'état parle d'une
invraisemblable accumulation de
manquements et de dysfonctionnements et
puis également donc nicole belloubet qui
diligente une inspection thomas clay est
ce que vous jugez que cette inspection
aujourd'hui elle est justifiée sur cette
affaire précisément des fadettes
mais je trouve que la milice de la
justice et le président de la république
d'ailleurs ont cédé un peu à la panique
dans des affaires où il faut plutôt
avoir raison garder en général et qu' il
n'y a pas de raison à ce stade me
semble-t-il de divinité dans une enquête
une inspection sauf évidemment a donné
raison à ceux qui critiquent le parquet
national financier je pense que il y a
dans notre système juridique des
possibilités de critiquer les décisions
de justice ça s'appelle les voies de
recours en appel un appel qui a été
formulée mais pour revenir à ce qui a
été dit jusqu'à présent que vous avez eu
l'air de dire qu'ils nous on aurait pu
reprocher à la justice d'avoir été trop
rapide
je voudrais quand même dire que à mon
avis la justice est exactement dans son
rôle au contraire lorsque dans une
affaire comme celle-ci qui est tenu par
une urgence et un calendrier électoral
elle arrive à fixer assez rapidement la
sphère fillon assez rapidement les
choses et qu'il fallait au contraire
qu'elle se prononce et qu'il fallait au
contraire et ce ne sont pas des
pressions n'y a pas de pression
lorsqu'on demande à transmettre le
dossier à un juge indépendant c'est tout
le contraire d'une pression c'est au
contraire de faire une enquête
indépendante
et pour terminer sur la question des
femmes est donc ça c'est l'autre volet
c'est le volet de la sphère sarkozy j'ai
l'impression que là encore c'est une
affaire qui est monté en épingle de
manière très artificielle là encore par
les personnes qui sont poursuivies mais
je vois mon ami patrick maisonneuve ne
pas être d'accord avec ça et je dirais
pour aller dans son sens qu
effectivement rien n'est plus déplaisant
et désagréable que mêmes inacceptable et
je les écris que dés magiques que des
avocats soient écoutés ou contrôlées par
l'intermédiaire des fadettes
mais je pense patron cher patrick je
pense quand même que en l'espèce il ya
une exagération de la faire ça ne
concernerait finalement qu'un seul
avocats eric dupont moretti
c'est encore trop un seul avocat bien
sûr mes eric dupond moretti bon ben
voilà on sait qu'il est gage être
écoutés ou s'écouter me même là il a
écouté je voulais cette phrase quand
même votre direction patrick maisonneuve
un certain eric dupond-moretti appelle
de ses voeux d'être écoutés ou
interceptés d'abord n'y a pas que eric
dupond-moretti ya d'autres avocats
alors pour que les choses soient bien
claires les avocats ne bénéficie pas
d'une impunité
de façon générale si un avocat est
suspecté et s'il ya des indices contre
cet avocat de franchir la ligne jaune et
notamment de pas respecté sa déontologie
il ya des des poursuites qui sont des
investigations les poursuites qui sont
posés là en l'occurrence de quoi
s'agit-il
j'ai compris qu'on cherchait une top qui
aurait donné des informations sur les
contacts entre nicolas sarkozy et son et
son avocat et qu'est-ce qu'on fait que
fait parquet national financier d'abord
le parquet de la salle financier
s'autosaisit de 7,2 cette problématique
alors quoi mon avis c'est pas vraiment
de la compétence du parc national
financier il ne fait pas ce genre
d'affaires ça dure des années
s'il n'y a pas de voie de recours comme
le dit thomas parce que le site n'aurait
deux fils mineurs qui est secret
personne n'a accès c'est un cette
enquête
elle est totalement dissimulé donc
personne ne peut faire de recours contre
les investigations qui sont menées et ça
va toucher des avocats si même le texte
si c'est pas le contenu des
conversations
il n'en demeure pas moins que le faire
des fadettes géolocalisés ça vous permet
de savoir qui rend qui appelle qui qu'il
parle à qui et à quel endroit
s'il n'y a pas une intrusion quelque
part dans le rapport confidentiel entre
l'avocat et ses interlocuteurs et ses
clients les mots n'ont plus de sens donc
la situation c'est pour vous mais
personnellement je trouve ça absolument
lamentable je trouve ça vraiment
invraisemblable je trouve vraiment léger
de la part du parquet national financier
je suis assez étonné d'ailleurs on
arrive à de telles situations on va
tenter d'élargir un petit peu notre
débat pour parler plus largement et bien
du parquet national financier puis
surtout la question de l'indépendance du
parquet je vous souhaite avant ça je
voudrais qu'on écoute un petit une
petite intervention de ce nicole
belloubet la garde des sceaux qui a tout
de même défendu le parquet national
financiers c'était chez nos confrères de
france inter
de mon point de vue le pnf à une
véritable utilité
vous le savez nous souhaitons je crois
que ça c'est une volonté commune que
portent nos concitoyens et que porte
également le parlement nous souhaitons
qu'il y ait une véritable répression de
la délinquance la grande délinquance
économique et financière
donc c'est une délinquance qui est
souvent extrêmement complexe parce que
il y à des questions vraiment très très
technique il faut des magistrats qui
soit compétent sur ces sujets là qui
suppose vraiment une expérience une
expertise jean pierre sfeir ce parc
national financiers il avait été créé à
la suite de
la sphère cahuzac on se le rappelle en
quelle est son utilité à quoi servait-il
qu'elle manque le net il comblait à
l'époque
écoutez monsieur clé alain stands il a
d'ailleurs écrit combien cette
institution est utile pour lutter contre
la délinquance financière économique et
c'est très bien
ce n'était pas le cas auparavant qu'est
ce que ça change et ça n'a l'air de
traiter un grand nombre de dossiers qui
étaient sans doute en attente mais ce
que je veux vous dire ici vraiment avant
de partir avant la fin de l'émission je
tiens le 17ème minute à je viens
justement je tiens à dire que il est
vraiment scandaleux inadmissible qu'il
est triste que l'on n'est pas encore
dans ce pays
voter un changement de la constitution
afin que les magistrats du parquet comme
les marchés sera du siège soit désigné
par une instance qui soit sans rapport
avec le pouvoir exécutif
voilà la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme condamne régulièrement la france
parce que le parquet n'est pas
indépendant et or et rassurez vous je ne
serai pas longtemps après mais j'insiste
l'assemblée nationale a voté un texte
pour dire que les magistrats du parquet
devait être nommé par le garde des
sceaux sur avis conforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature en 2013 qu
est ce qu a fait le sénat en 2013
j étais je m'en souviens on a voté le
même texte comme le même texte a été
voté par les deux assemblées
vous êtes d'accord il nommé il n'y a
aucun obstacle à ce qu'il soit soumis au
congrès et qu'on change la constitution
de manière à installer l'indépendance du
parquet sur le plan de la nomination de
la gestion des carrières et du régime
disciplinaire
on peut le faire et pourquoi ne le
fait-on pas et lâche midi pour une
raison très simple c'est que monsieur le
président de la république a dit on va
faire une réforme constitutionnelle très
bien il ya six ou sept points ou au
sénat on est d'accord même tous courants
confondus il ya des larges
asus et dont celui ci mais comme le
président de la république tient à ce
que dans ce paquet il y est la réduction
du nombre de sénateurs la
proportionnelle et deux députés
voici ces blocs est telle qu'à chaque
bsa tenait ce jeudi jean pierre met du
temps avec françois hollande c'est aussi
bloqué pour des raisons politiques mais
il y en a marre il y à des réformes
nécessaires comme celle là mais rien
n'empêche de la faire on peut faire
plusieurs réformes constitutionnelles
mais je dis ici sur public sénat je
m'adresse au président de la république
il faut que je lui dis mais pourquoi
vous ne proposez pas cette réforme sur
laquelle il y aurait un consensus et qui
nous éviterait beaucoup de ces
polémiques parce que le parquet aurait
l'indépendance nécessaire à l'égard du
pouvoir exécutif juridique katia du bras
est votre réaction je pense que vous
êtes d'accord avec tout le monde va être
d'accord là dessus mais ça n'empêche ces
sujets sur lequel tout le monde est
d'accord c'est le serpent de mer
politique et à chaque fois qu'on est au
pouvoir cndd se effet par cc l'amant
dans lequel vous avez les dires du
braille le problème je pense qu'il
faudrait le demander à nos responsables
politiques qui se sont succédé depuis 20
ans manifestement ça reste toujours une
tentation de pouvoir garder la main sur
la carrière des magistrats du parquet et
en ce qui concerne ce pouvoir il
assumait d'ailleurs une façon enfin dans
son pouvoir de nomination des pauvres
des magistrats du parquet une forme d'un
tweet eu personne et qui d'ailleurs est
très gênant quand notre premier ministre
a déclaré à l'assemblée au parlement
il ya deux ans que il était c'était
normal qu'ils nomment un procureur paris
qu'ils soient en ligne avec ses idées et
à l'aise avec lequel ils se sentent à
l'aise c'est quand même très pro les
mêmes pas et du fait que la chancellerie
avait proposé plusieurs noms qui ont été
retoqués par tout à fait l'exécutif 1
par le premier ministre et puis on a eu
l'impression qu'il choisissait
finalement son procureur est d'ailleurs
j'ajoute que la réforme bien sûr ce
serait un pas déjà que cette réforme qui
a été votée dans les mêmes termes par
les deux assemblées puisse être votée
mais ce serait seulement un premier pas
parce que dans cette ce texte procureur
de la république continue enfin
contrairement au président d'être
hinault et aux premiers présidents des
cours d'appel qui sont nommés
directement par le conseil de la
magistrature dans le texte qui a été
voté qui pourrait repasser pour être
adoptée c'est simplement un avis
conforme du conseil sportlab et raturer
c'est pas du tout la même chose
d'important c'est important ça serait un
pas en avant
c'est un oui ce serait un premier pas ça
ta fille conforme du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature patrick maisonneuve
mais c'est pas la réelle indépendance à
philippe harquet par rapport à
l'exécutif a fait plus de trente ans que
j'interviens dans ce qu'on appelle les
affaires politico-financières plus de 30
ans et l'indépendance du parquet savait
plus de trente ans que lorsque l'on n'en
parle
quand j'entends monsieur ciotti venir de
donner des leçons et d'en appeler la
suppression d'un du parquet national
financiers les amis monsieur ciotti ont
également été était au pouvoir un mot un
moment x que n'ont pas fait la la
réforme met donc je suis d'accord bien
sûr cependant mais je mets un petit un
petit bémol
et d'ailleurs je dirais les vêtements la
du parquet national financiers et
l'intervention sur les fadettes et des
avocats
il faudrait quand même imaginer et
prévoir une possibilité de contrôle du
parquet du procureur
tout pouvoir sans aucun endroit ils
feraient justement prévoir leurs listes
de contrôle notamment peut être au
niveau du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature composé éventuellement
d'ailleurs de façon majoritaire de non
magistrats du parquet mais on peut on
peut imaginer une autre une autre une
autre composition et je voudrais je
souhaiterais et personnellement je suis
pas le seul je sais que ma voisine de
droite l'ont pas être d'accord avec ce
avec ce point là une séparation
alors ce qui concerne les juges
procureurs et les juges du siège
faut-il une plus grande distance entre
les uns et les autres et que le juge du
siège de vienne un véritable juge du
contrôle de ce que demande de ce que
propose le parc et je crois que c'est
ces deux points sous lesquelles si on va
vers cette réforme qu'il faudra aborder
mais thomas clay s'il y avait bien ce
problème d'indépendance du parquet
est-ce que cela n'entretient pas la
suspicion voire est ce que les soupçons
du coup ne sont pas fondées ce tome on
dit qu'il ya quand même un problème
d'indépendance du parquet en réalité il
n'y a pas de problème d'indépendance du
parquet parce que le parquet est
indépendant il ne peut pas recevoir
d'instructions individuel en revanche on
donne des aliments à ceux qui sont
poursuivis qui vont crier à la justice
politique précisément parce que cette
indépendance n'est pas entré encore dans
la constitution
moi je bois les paroles qui sont qui
sont dites sur votre plateau et en
particulier celle du sénateur sûr je me
suis tu je me souviens très bien du rôle
qu'il avait eue en 2013 sur le projet de
loi constitutionnelle je crois que vous
étiez monsieur le sénateur rapporteur de
la commission des lois à l'époque et
qu'effectivement le processus est enrayé
parce qu'il n'avait pas la majorité
pressenti des trois cinquièmes au
parlement est là pour aller dans le sens
de ce que de ce qui est dit ce serait
quand même extraordinaire si cette
opposition qui fait consensus n'était
pas présente et surtout au moment où on
a appris à 48 heures que le président de
la république envisagée par des
référendums y compris constitutionnel
pour y insérer les conclusions de la
convention citoyenne sur le climat c'est
le véhicule idéal pour faire cette
réforme constitutionnelle qui est une
réforme encore une fois extrêmement
consensuelle simplement moi j'observe
comme vos invités que depuis 20 ans n'en
parle que depuis vingt ans il ya un
consensus notamment dans les oppositions
et puis quand on arrive au pouvoir
ça a été le cas ce quinquennat roland
c'est sans doute le cas aujourd'hui sous
le quinquennat mapon et bien finalement
le consensus se fissure et la majorité
au pouvoir quel qu'il soit qu'elles
soient de gauche ou qu'elle soit de
droite et je ne vise encore une fois pas
du tout ici jean pierre sueur parce que
lui avait eu un rôle proactif en 2013
et bien finalement laisse tomber cette
réforme constitutionnelle parce qu'on
aime bien
avoir le sentiment est à mon avis c'est
plus c'est un sentiment qu'une vérité de
tenir le parquet aurait une courte et
bien merci beaucoup à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat et ce débat
qui se termine donc et bien sûr l'espoir
d'une révision constitutionnelle pour
enfin résoudre ce serpent de mer
politique merci à tous les quatre dans
une demi-heure le temps fort de cette
émission les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement il va y avoir plusieurs
questions sur les propositions de la
convention citoyenne surtout sur le fait
qu emmanuel macron promettent de
transmettre l'essentiel de ses
propositions par des décrets des projets
de loi et un référendum on vient d'en
parler ont de quoi faire réagir les
parlementaires mais d'abord on
s'intéresse au texte débattu cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle et qui vit
parle de la dette qu'ovide et de sa
prise en charge par la sécurité sociale
on va parler de tout ça avec deux
invités sur ce plateau mais d'abord on
rejoint alexandre poussard salle à des
conférences vous êtes avec le sénateur
centriste olivier henno effectivement
entamé la dette du coronavirus qui
s'élève à 136 milliards d'euros eh bien
elle va être transféré dans la caisse de
la sécurité sociale alors olivier henno
est ce que c'est à la sécurité sociale
de payer la facture du cours des virus
alors c'est la logique de la cad s
d'amortir la dette sociale de cette
caisse
donc comme vous l'avez dit 136 milliards
prolongation des remboursements sur neuf
ans donc jusqu'en 2033 pour que ce soit
supportable en termes de prélèvements
obligatoires
nous sommes dans une circonstance
exceptionnelle avec cette crise
sanitaire
donc il n'est pas totalement illogique
on croyait en avoir fini avec la can est
sans la fin de l'année bon à l'évidence
et savait c'est pas le cas nous devons
prolonger
absolument 7 cette dette ce qui s'est
passé en fait c'est que nous nous
acceptons en termes de prélèvement est
cette logique mais nous voulons adopter
deux amendements
un premier amendement pour ne pas
accepter le transfert de la dette
sociale c'est le sens du rapport le
transfert de la dette des hôpitaux
c'est le sens du rapport de jean marie
vanlerenberghe et puis aussi
un autre amendement qui prévoit d'un
style et d'installer la règle la règle
d'or pour qu'on en finisse enfin avec ce
remboursement de la dette sociale est ce
que ce ne serait pas aussi à l'état de
payer une partie de la dette du corona
virus notamment compte tenu de
l'impréparation de notre administration
de l'état face à la crise sanitaire
alors c'est la raison de l'amendement
par rapport au transfert de la dette des
hôpitaux parce que là il nous semble que
on n'est pas dans la logique de la cades
est ce la logique de la cades est ce
c'est l'amortissement de la dette
sociale
là on est pour ce qui concerne les
hôpitaux sur des investissements et donc
ça ne paraît pas très clair très très
logique
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
groupe va soutenir l'amendement déposé
par jean marie vanlerenberghe
alors si la sécurité sociale supporte la
dette du coroner virus au final ce sont
les salariés les retraités qui vont
payer la facture avec une hausse de csg
alors c'est la logique du crds c'est
depuis 1996 que c'est comme ça on
croyait en avoir terminé la dernière
cotisation pour payer la dette sociale
c'est évident que ça n'est pas
satisfaisant 1 puisque on fait payer
d'aider des coûts de fonctionnement des
soins des de la santé de la retraite par
les générations à venir c'est pour ça
que pour en finir avec cette logique
nous voulons introduire la règle d'or
c'est cette logique c'est pas un projet
de loi anodin puisqu'il ya aussi la
question de la cinquième branche la
branche autonomie c'est un projet de loi
très important 136 milliards à la cades
s est la cinquième branche la branche
autonomie et oui la cinquième branche de
la sécurité sociale pour lutter contre
la dépendance merci beaucoup
olivier henno pour votre intervention
vous c'est à vous tous merci beaucoup
alexandre on poursuit le débat sur ce
plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
daniel chastain ans bonjour boucherie
nateur les indépendants de la chorale
vice président de la commission des
affaires sociales et jean louis touraine
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste
d'ille et vilaine et membre de la
commission des affaires sociales on va
commencer bien sûr ce projet de loi
débattu cet après midi et qui parle de
la prise en charge de la dette qu vide
alors qu'il doit prendre en charge le
déficit lié à la crise du cowitz la
première question posée par le projet
loi qui lui prévoit daniel chasse à un
transfert sur les comptes de la sécurité
sociale
si vous voulez le fait de la sécurité
sociale c'est qu'il ya une déficit au
niveau des entrées à la sécurité sociale
parce qu'il ya une baisse absolument des
salaires de la masse salariale et bien
sûr c'est normal que ce soit la sécurité
sociale qui prennent en charge parce que
eh bien tout penser qu'elle faisait mal
à les malades du coup vite et la dette
du coc vite c'est normal que ce soit la
sécurité sociale qui le prennent
intervalle or il ya effectivement la
dette
la reprise de la dette des hôpitaux de
13 milliards qui avait été incluse et le
gouvernement effectivement dans le
projet de loi avait indiqué que c'était
le l'état qui devrait on devait pendant
pas en charge c'est 13 milliards donc ça
effectivement à les faire débattre en
tout cas pour l'instant le texte prévoit
et bien d'ajouter 136 milliards d'euros
au trou de la sécu jean louis touraine
vous vous y opposer alors ils n'ajoutent
pas sur 36 milliards dans les 136
milliards sont inclus l'ensemble des
dettes de l'état alors sur sur le point
de la légitimité du transfert de l'état
vers la sécurité sociale je pense qu'il
ya tout de même un certain nombre
d'éléments dont il faut tenir compte le
premier c'est que la dette intérieure et
de 31 milliards oui qui avaient été
creusées d'ailleurs par le fait que en
partie par le fait que l'état a pris un
certain nombre de décisions notamment
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
la suppression du forfait social qui
sont des décisions de l'état et qu'il
impute à la sécurité sociale sur les
conséquences du coc vide ses 92
milliards d'euros
c'est ce qui fait les 92 milliards plus
les 13 milliards pour les hôpitaux
l'hôpital tout a fait d 92 milliards
c'est les dépenses liées aux qu'ovide et
notamment le manque de rentrées d'argent
dont parlent les uns monsieur chat 5 et
qui sont des exonérations des
entreprises peau pour un motif que l'on
peut partager simplement c'est à l'état
d'assumer les conséquences
ça changerait que ce serait une prise en
charge par l'état absolument j'ajoute
que l'état lui quand il ambre quand il
leur en bourse il ne rembourse que les
intérêts qu'ils empruntent à chaque fois
le capital ça représenterait pour l'état
ça représenterait 1 milliard 1 milliard
500 millions d'euros dans ses rangs
chose en fait tu as fait et ça va
représenter pour la sécurité sociale ça
va représenter 12 milliards d'euros
c'est dire que vous allez peut-être nous
poser la question sur les perspectives
en direction de la santé de l'hôpital
c'est dire que les moyens qui restent
pour l'hôpital vont être sérieusement
amputé c'est un problème ça daniel
chassaing pourquoi ne pas et bien avoir
une prise en charge par l'état si cela
ne représente pas grand chose pour lui
et alors que et bien pour la sécurité
sociale
au contraire cela peut tout changer non
mais si vous voulez il y a eu une
diminution des masques de la masse
salariale
c'est comme ça c'est la maladie les gens
ont été obligés d'être confiné c'est ça
fait partie de la maladie donc ça me
paraît normal
effectivement que soit la sécurité
sociale les 80 les 92 milliards
effectivement c'est une estimation de la
date 2020 2021 et 2022
donc moi je pense que c'est tout à fait
normal
alors là la cades est ce la caisse
d'amortissement à la dette sociale va
être différée de 2024 à 2033 plus neuf
ans bon ça me paraît normal c'est une
épidémie c'est de la faute de personne
c'est pas de la faute de l'état non plus
donc voilà je vous dis on pourrait faire
autrement oui d'autant que c'est pas
c'est pas justifié c'est qu'il y ait eu
des malades et qu'il y ait eu des
salaires en moins c'est une évidence à
porte sur deux mois mais l'essentiel de
la dette à venir c'est parce que vous
l'avez vous avez raison de dire que ça
va pas ça va se poursuivre sur 21 22
c'est l'accumulation de l'ensemble des
déficits qui va amener à cette date
236,1 milliards d'euros l'essentiel les
gens seront pas malade davantage dans
les années qui viennent c'est
l'exonération qui a été accordé des
cotisations sociales à un certain nombre
d'entreprises oui
c'est aussi une diminution de la masse
salariale c'est-à-dire une diminution
des rentrées de la sécurité sociale
parce que effectivement les entreprises
n'ont pas travaillé
voilà c'est pas que les exonérations
tepa 92 milliards mais c'est la 4e fois
c'est marginal par rapport à ce qu'ils
aient consenti alors le projet de loi
prévoit également la création d'un
cinquième risque assuré par la sécurité
sociale ça signifie donc ajoutés aux
quatre risques existants c'est 80 c'est
la santé accidents du travail et
maladies professionnelles famille
retraite
un cinquième sur l'autonomie et la
dépendance ça pour le coup jean louis
touraine c'est consensuel la création
d'un cinquième risque ou pas la
déclaration oui l'état sort ça fait des
dizaines d'années que qu'on évoque cette
cette question et tous les gouvernements
successifs que ce soit celui de sarkozy
de monsieur hollande ont buté devant les
conséquences financières et les
difficultés qui les attendait or
aujourd'hui qu'elle elle c'est juste une
annonce c'est on vous dit on va mettre
en place une cinquième branche sais pas
si c'est une cinquième branche ou un
cinquième risque parce que c'est pas la
même chose mais savoir je sais
d'ailleurs pas de risque mais le risque
n'est pas défini du tout dans son
périmètre est ce que c'est le risque d
pour les personnes âgées
est ce que les personnes en situation de
handicap sont intégrés
quels sont les moyens qu'on va mettre en
face pour financer tout cela comment les
départements vont ils d'être intégrées
parce que il représente à peu près 18 %
du financement de la dépendance par
conséquent et tout un tas d'acteurs qui
sont qui interviennent quelle va être la
part de l'état est-ce que ça va encore
être un transfert sur la sécurité
sociale bref des tas de questions qui
sont pas résolues et qui est qu'ils
n'ont pas de réponses dans la
proposition qui est faite kiwis qui est
une question de communication pour
laquelle sans doute on a beaucoup
c'était un peu la charrue avant les
boeufs daniel chassaing parce qu' un
rapport qui doit être remis au mois de
septembre qui va parler un peu tous ces
sujets il a donc on parle de ses
cinquièmes
alors ce n'est qu'une annonce pour la
saur écoutez moi oui c'est qu'une
annonce mais malheureusement depuis
lionel jospin on parle de ce cinquième
risque et n'a jamais été mis en place
donc moi je suis favorable jeu très
satisfait qu'ils aient ce cinquième
risque qu'ils soient mis en place
qu'est ce que ça va permettre alors
l'instauration de ce cinquième risque
parce que l'autonomie elle est prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale mais à
cheval entre les différents oui l'isq de
la sécurité sociale comment ça se passe
là risque l'autonomie est pris en charge
si vous voulez au niveau des personnes
âgées par l'état qui subventionne le
département mais c'est en gros pris en
charge aux trois quarts aux deux tiers
par le document
donc le fait que seul état maintenant
dans la sécurité sociale et je pensais
une équité au niveau de la nation je
pense que c'est une bonne chose mais
effectivement je pense que le
gouvernement prévoit seulement 2
millions de 3 en 2014
c'est à dire 0 15% de la cg c'est pas
suffisant il faut que dès 2021
parce que actuellement le personnel en
ehpad et à domicile n'est pas suffisant
et il faut absolument que il y ait une
augmentation d'environ on peut estimer à
20% du nombre de personnes en ehpad
donc il faut commencer dès 2021 parce
que pour arriver à avoir actuellement et
un encadrement dans les ehpad de 0,6
faudrait qu'on arrive à 0,7 ou 0,8 20%
de plus et je pense que pour ça il faut
au moins 4 ou 6 à 6 milliards fait que
en 2024 si on veut vraiment être prêt
mais il faut commencer dès 2021 pour
dans le plfss 2020'' budget de la
sécurité sociale envisagé une déjà un
financement de l'autonomie je suis là je
suis d'accord sur les conclusions
simplement c'est pas dans la déclaration
qu'on sait pas comment ça va être
financé tout ce qui est dit jusqu'à
présent
c'est que on va prendre une part de la
csg à partir de 2024 et ça va
représenter deux milliards 3 mais si
l'on considère aujourd'hui la situation
le simple actualisation à partir de
l'augmentation de la population dans la
population de plus de 75 ans simplement
pour satisfaire sans améliorer le
service et on sait combien il est
dégradé on a vu les grandes manifs et
2018 et le rapport de dominique libault
indique bien que 1 pour satisfaire et
actualisées il faut déjà 2 milliards 1
c'est à dire on consomme l'ensemble de
ce qui est prélevé sur la csg pour
améliorer le service faire en sorte et
je suis d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit par monsieur chat 5
il faut aux alentours d'après monsieur
li bo moi j'ai pas vérifié ces chiffres
le 4 milliards 8 c'est à dire qu'il faut
trouver 7 milliards par an dans les
premières années pour aller jusqu'à plus
de 10 milliards en 2030
c'est dire que le compte n'y est pas et
que la façon de transférer on en a parlé
dans quelques instants
des devoirs de l'état des charges de
l'état sur la sécurité sociale ne va pas
favoriser la mise en oeuvre de ce
cinquième risque en tout cas les limites
de notre système de prise en charge des
personnes âgées ont été aussi démontrer
avec cette crise sanitaire du coc vie
d'un sujet sur lequel planche le
parlement le sénat alan sa commission d'
enquête tandis que l'assemblée nationale
a auditionné hier agnès buzyn l'ex
ministre des solidarités de la santé oms
l'écoutant il n'y a pas une journée où
ne prenons pas des décisions par une
journée où nous n'avons pas anticipé
toujours par rapport à l' oms ecdc nous
sommes toujours en avance par rapport
aux décisions internationales donc en
aucun cas je peux vous dire qu en aucun
cas je peux laisser dire que le
ministère de la santé a été lent voilà
pour cette intervention à d'agnès juin
tandis que l'on voit que ça commence à
arriver dans la salle des conférences du
sénat et vous voyez est notamment le
premier ministre edward philippins qui
est présent pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
qui commence dans
un quart d'heure alors d'abord votre
votre commentaire daniel chassaing sur
ce que vient de dire eh bien l'ex
ministre de la santé agnès buzyn pour
elle la france était extrêmement bien
préparées à la pandémie
bien sûr dans le contexte de polémique
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui alors si
vous voulez mon cette pandémie d'abord
elle était imprévisible et inédite
effectivement l'om est-ce au mois de
janvier
j'ai pas la date précise mais indiqué
qu'il y avait très peu de chances pour
que ça arrive en europe
mon c'est vrai que alors ce que
l'épidémie est arrivé notamment disons
fin février début mars
on peut dire que on n'était pas
suffisamment préparé est ce que c'était
prévisible
voilà un haut niveau surtout au niveau
des masques et des tests oui on peut
dire ça
alors après qui qui est responsable ce
qui est responsable c'est d'abord le
virus parce que on s'attendait pas à ce
que ce virus
d'après des informations des fermes
comme ça sur toute l'europe
jean louis touraine vous votre réaction
à cette défense inde agnès buzyn est
elle pour vous convaincante elle a été
attaquée sur le manque de ré d'activité
et d'anticipation qu'il y avait pu avoir
dans la part de son ministère au plus à
considérer que madame +11 dit des tas de
choses des des vérités leur contraire
vous fait notamment référence à son
interview dans le monde lorsqu'elle a pu
dire on aurait dû tout arrêter c'était
une mascarade
il ya eu beaucoup de propos de la aussi
déclaré au début du coronavirus on peut
lui pardonner mais enfin il faut quand
même pas quelle ce qu'elle se dédouane
de cette façon elle a aussi déclaré
qu'il veut pratiquement aucune chance
pour que le virus
oui en chine et viennent jusqu'à nous
c'est tout un certain nombre de
déclarations
oui et puis d'autre part il ya une
commission d' enquête qui est en cours
par conséquent je vais pas me prononcer
avant j'ai pas suffisamment
d'informations pour dire si on a été à
la hauteur par la hauteur les
comparaisons internationales ne sont pas
favorables mais ça ne veut rien dire il
faut peut être regarder les raisons pour
lesquelles ça s'est passé de cette façon
autre conséquence du coc vide les
discussions qui sont ouvertes dans le
cadre du ségur de la santé des
discussions qui doivent aboutir dans
quelques jours et qui pour l'instant ne
satisfont guère les soignants ces
soignants qu'on a plus
issayas qui sont aujourd'hui dans la rue
ils réclament plus de moyens ils
réclament une revalorisation de salaire
le gouvernement met 3 milliards 6 sur la
table mais le compte n'y est pas pour
les soignants daniel chassaing il ya
notamment et bien 300 millions seulement
pour les médecins hospitaliers qui 2 10
et bien c'est des mesurettes c'est du
saupoudrage bon et c'est vrai que les
médecins hospitaliers ne doivent être
réévalué dans l'ordre dans leur salaire
je suis tout à fait d'accord comme tout
le personnel puisque on se rend compte
que les infirmières basson par rapport à
nos voisins européens
beaucoup moins mal payés et donc il faut
absolument revaloriser le salaire des
infirmières et des aides soignantes même
dû tous les salariés mais surtout
effectivement des infirmières et des
aides soignantes qui joue bien sûr un
rôle considérable dans l'hôpital dans
les ehpad partout et que si vous voulez
le gouvernement d'après ce que j'avais
compris c'était une proposition de six
milliards d'euros
je ne sais pas c'est quand même une
somme qui est conséquente mais en tout
cas je suis bien sûr tout à fait
favorable à ce que souhaitait et les
hommes dames d'ailleurs depuis 2012
inquiété en 2012 et 2017 était de 2%
alors qu'on sait très bien que pour
continuer l'hôpital il fallait augmenter
de 4% et augmenter davantage si on veut
augmenter les salaires du personnel ce
qui est tout à fait normal votre
réaction
pour conclure jean louis touraine à ce
secteur de la santé et les
manifestations des soignants qui se
poursuivent oui elles ont eu lieu
d'ailleurs bien avant le virus et par
conséquent elle reflétait la situation
de l'hôpital quelles que soient par
ailleurs les responsabilités elles sont
pas les seuls de ce à la seule charge de
ce gouvernement
il n'en reste pas moins que l'expression
quoi qu'il en coûte commence à avoir ses
limites
on voit bien qu'on est en train de
mégoter alors que c'était pendant la
pandémie oui on a raison les aides
soignantes
elles sont les plus mal rémunérés
peut-être deux
d'europe les infirmières sont dans la
même situation et le rapport qui a été
établi par elle comme rim bas madame l
comrie sur la situation de l'emploi
notamment dans les secteurs
médico-social montre que quelques uns
ont pourra développer les capacités
d'accueil
le nombre de personnels à l'intérieur
des ehpad il n'y aura pas de candidature
tout simplement parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de nos concitoyennes
concitoyens qui ne veulent plus exercer
cette profession compte tenu des
contraintes des difficultés et des baies
des salaires qui sont aussi bas oui on
veut un gros problème aussi du nombre
rejoins mon collègue du nombre
d'infirmières et d'aides-soignantes faut
absolument en augmentant les salaires
aussi avoir un plan de formation parce
que sinon on va avoir une pénurie
d'infirmières et de formation et
attractivité de l'hôpital public merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce face à face place à
présent sans transition à l'audition ce
matin de l'ambassadeur de turquie en
france alors que la tension monte
en méditerranée les relations entre
paris et ankara sont très dégradés au
coeur de leur désaccord la situation
libyenne
la turquie reproche à la france d'avoir
soutenu le camp du maréchal haftar non
reconnu par les nations unies écoutez
quand certains mais soutient autres fins
terroristes quand même haftar c'est pas
c'est pas le la personne la plus
légitime qu'on puisse trouver en libye
quand on le soutient on ne joue pas un
jeu dangereux
et quand on se soutient le gouvernement
légitime alors la sûreté joue un jeu
dangereux
c'est quand même un tort à votre ami et
allié turc non vous ne pensez pas voilà
pourrait bien cet extrait de cette
audition ce matin alors que l'on voit
qu'ils commencent à arriver du monde
salle des conférences avant les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
tout de suite la réaction de cédric
perrin il est à votre micro
alexandre cédric terrain qui est
vice-président de la commune c'est des
affaires étrangères effectivement entamé
dans cette audition l'ambassadeur turc à
dénoncer à demi-mot le soutien de la
france à l'armée du maréchal haftar en
libye qui n'est pas reconnue par la
communauté internationale alors cédric
perrin qui avez vous pensé de ces
critiques de l'ambassadeur turc sur la
politique internationale française
écoutez l'ambassadeur a tenu son rôle
d'ambassadeur c'est à dire qu'il a
défendu la position de la turquie qui
pour qui à nos yeux est difficilement
défendable compte tenu du contexte et
compte tenu de ce qui se passe là bas ce
qui est certain c'est que la france
parle à tout le monde c'est quelque
chose qui est très important qu'on a
rappelé à l'ambassadeur que moi j'ai dit
ramasse adore également après que le
président allait rappeler que la france
est le pays des droits de l'homme et que
la france était un pays qui défendent la
liberté partout où elle devait la
défendre et que dans ce contexte il
d'amanlis bien c'est exactement la même
situation et j'avais fait un rapport
avec mes collègues via les guérini
il ya deux ans maintenant sur la libye
on avait prévu un certain nombre de
choses qui malheureusement se sont se
sont déroulées la france a essayé en
tout cas dans un certain nombre de 2,2
points de rendez vous de régler un
certain nombre de choses et ça n'a pas
pu se faire
mais en tout cas la france aujourd'hui
continue de parler à tout le monde et
les attaques verbales libyenne turc
pardon
non pas de sens parce que c'est pal
c'est pas le sens de ce que la france
fait en libye alors des attaques
verbales mais également des tensions
militaires et d'ailleurs l'ambassadeur
turc est revenu sur l'incident maritime
en méditerranée entre une frégate
française et des navires militaires
turcs
est-ce que vous avez cru la version des
faits de l'ambassadeur côté
l'ambassadeur a donné sa version des
faits celle qui lui avait vraisemblable
est vraisemblablement été donné par la
marine turque
nous avons évidemment une tout autre une
totale une tout autre analyse des choses
il apparut anormal à l'ambassadeur de
turquie 15 navires de marchandises se
fasse contrôlé trois fois par des
navires grecs français et italiens il
nous est paru à nous complètement
anormal qu'un marque qu'un navire de
marchandises qui par définition
transportait a priori d'après les dires
turque du matériel pour les ong soient
antic a accompagné par trois navires
turcs
donc effectivement il ya eu des demandes
qui ont été faites par les navires
français dans le cadre de la mission qui
lui était confiée par le courbet dans le
cadre de la mission qui lui était
confiée par l'otan et nous avons le
président la république l'a dit était
particulièrement choquée par la manière
dont les le contact a été pris par les
navires turcs en direction du navire du
navire français puisque il a été plutôt
malmené alors l'ambassadeur a parlé de
queue de poisson vraiment là ce sont des
mots sur lesquels il joue avec beaucoup
de avec beaucoup de classe parce qu'il
faut dire quand même qu'il est
parfaitement
il est très habile en la matière mais
évidemment nous n'avons pour nous nous
avons pour nous la version qui nous a
été donné par la marine française et que
nous croyons évidemment complètement
est ce que la turquie a encore sa place
dans l'otan dans l'alliance atlantique
qui emmanuel macron et bien qualifiés
d'organisations en état de mort
cérébrale écoutez
les propos du président étaient un peu
au dur même si il reflète une certaine
certaines un certain questionnement
aujourd'hui moi je suis rapporteur
général la commission sécurité et
défense et j'ai malheureusement
l'occasion quand je suis à l'otan que
mes collègues de voir le l'agressivité
et la provocation permanente que font
les parlementaires turcs est donc
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons dit à
l'ambassadeur c'est qu'il était
nécessaire que la claque à la nature qui
clarifie sa position vis à vis de l'otan
parce que je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important aujourd'hui entre
alliés on ne se on ne se on ne se traite
pas comme ça a été fait entre le courbet
lé navire turc merci beaucoup assez
d'expérience pour votre intervention
et voilà il faut que la turquie clarifie
ses positions sur la libye et oui
réelles tensions entre ankara et paris
une interview pendant laquelle on a pu
voir également arriver le président du
sénat gérard larcher qui va donc
présider cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui va
s'ouvrir dans quelques minutes tout
autre sujet on va parler et bien avec
françoise laborde sénatrice de la haute
garonne de la situation de l'industrie
aéronautique
alexandre c'est à vous et oui alors
qu'airbus a annoncé la suppression de 15
mille postes dans le monde 5000 postes
en france françoise laborde on imagine
que cela va être un cataclysme pour
votre territoire toulousain qui abritent
beaucoup d'emplois d'airbus tout à fait
c'est très embêtant pour sur la région
le département mais aussi tout le pays
et je pense que 5000 emplois en france
c'est très embêtant parce que c'est
toute une filière aéronautique donc ce
n'est pas seulement 5000 emplois chez
airbus
c'est aussi beaucoup d'emplois chez des
sous traitants les équipementiers et
quand même 450 équipementiers et il y a
aussi déjà des plans sociaux qui sont
chez daher chez derichebourg sécher
sogeclair et je pense que tout le monde
se dit ça va arriver chez nous donc en
tant qu'élu local
est-ce que vous avez déjà une estimation
de et bien la suppression totale de
postes dans le secteur aného
aéronautique dans votre territoire
tout ça va aller autour de 3000 4000
emplois parce que ce ne sont pas je vous
dis que airbus airbus et 5000 en france
mais c'est tous les autres et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment qu'il y
des réunions de les collectivités les
postes intermédiaires l'état parce que
nous avons quand même entendu bercy dire
c'est peut-être énorme par rapport à
l'argent mis sur la table à une quasi
milliards d'euros bien sûr il ya 7
milliards pour air france met 7
milliards air france et les avions aussi
ce sont les lignes commerciales donc
l'un entraîne l'autre il ne faudrait pas
qu'on n'arrive pas empêché cette
hémorragie parce que quand elle va se
faire
elle sera tellement énorme comme pourra
plus l'arrêter et si on peut l'arrêter
c'est maintenant et justement compte
tenu de ces milliards d'euros dette de
l'état
est ce que le gouvernement ne doit pas
être plus fermes pour interdire par
exemple des licenciements secs chez
airbus alors moi je suis d'accord je
pense qu'il faut d'abord bien sûr voir
les licenciements ce qu'on appelle non
contre 1 c'est à dire peut-être des
départs en retraite anticipés mais il
faut faire attention aussi parce que
nous avons des compétences et nous avons
des apprentis et si les tuteurs qui sont
vers la retraite s'en vont nous n'aurons
plus ses compétences boeing va très mal
la chine n'est pas pour l'instant en
compétences d'être vraiment en
concurrence avec nous mais peut par
contre nous racheter encore des savoir
faire et ça aussi il faut s'en méfier
très bien merci beaucoup françoise
laborde de nous avoir cessé la situation
toulousaine qui est touchée par ces
suppressions de postes chez airbus et
oui elle sera vigilante françoise
laborde avec ses grandes inquiétudes
pour la filière aéronautique est elle
effectivement particulièrement concernés
autre sujet qui va largement marqué
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
les suites de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat jean luc fichet sénateur
socialiste va interroger le gouvernement
sur ce sujet et il est d'ailleurs à
votre micro alexandre jean luc huyse
jean luc fichet pardon le président de
la république reprend la majeure partie
des propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat est ce que vous
êtes satisfait par cette décision d'
emmanuel macron pas goûté satisfait de
fait l'euro près de 140 649 ma foi c'est
pas trop mal ce qui moi me déçoit
beaucoup c'est que il avait expliqué
dans les suites à la convention
citoyenne que justement ils feront en
sorte que les usines soient maintenues
dans les territoires et qu'elles ne
soient pas concentrés dans les grandes
métropoles il se trouve que
parallèlement à son discours
moi j'habite à un pays s'appelle région
de morlaix dans le finistère où on ferme
une centre de maintenance up brit air et
on va liquider deux chansons de ces
emplois dans les mois qui viennent
et donc je pense qu'il a il ya problème
entre l'effet d'annoncé puis la réalité
du terrain donc on a là dessus sur doute
quelque chose à faire donc pour vous le
gouvernement doit revenir sur cette
décision de fermer elle a une grande
partie des liaisons à mes supérieurs en
france mais il faut absolument qu'on
fasse attention d'autant que une fois
qu'on aura fermé des liaisons aériennes
la question c'est comment on va gérer
l'embolisation qui va se faire sur le
ferroviaire parce que tous ces gens qui
prennent l'avion qui vont revenir vers
des trains qui voudront avoir des trains
rapides des trains premium donc on aura
certainement une vraie question dans les
mois à venir sur la question du
transport y la décentralisation
l'abandon des 110 kg 110 km/heure sur
les autoroutes c'est une bonne décision
pour les territoires alors vous savez
moi je faisais partie des gens qui avait
rédigé un rapport sur les 90 km heure
justement pour des raisons économiques
aussi aider des questions de temps
d'accès
au territoire - les 110 km heure très
honnêtement j'ai pas de débat là dessus
je suis à 110 ou 130 ça ne me gêne pas
du tout je crois que voilà c'est pas un
problème pour vous ça fait pas de
différence pour moi ce fut alors le
président la république a l'air plutôt
ouvert 1 et bien une révision de la
constitution notamment pour y inclure la
protection de l'environnement
c'est important pour vous de faire cette
révision est qu'il y ait un référendum
là dessus absolument je trouve que
souvent inscrit dans la constitution
c'est effectivement une très bonne chose
parce que on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on
ne pourra pas revenir en arrière la
question de l'environnement allée
centrale
cet après midi je vais interroger le
premier ministre sur cette question
justement en termes d'alimentation en
termes d'environnement et je pense que
bien évidemment en plus l'utilisation du
référendum
c'est quelque chose qui était promis
donc qu'ils soient utilisés fois
pourquoi pas et justement sur le
référendum est ce que c'est pas un peu
cosmétique de juste mettre quelques mots
dans la constitution
ah bah non enfin c'est pas cosmétiques
serre que on peut imaginer qu'on y met
beaucoup plus de choses maintenant que
tu as à faire de la constitution
comprendra beaucoup de volets et donc il
faudra faire en sorte que si on veut que
la modification de la constitution se
fasse les textes soient validées par une
majorité et donc bah faudrait y
travailler beaucoup dans tous les cas
c'est important qu'on puisse inscrire
l'environnement dans la constitution et
vous êtes favorable à un référendum plus
large où on va poser plusieurs questions
écologiques aux français en 2021 alors
moi je crois que attention le référendum
ça peut être tout et n'importe quoi si
on veut vraiment faire un référendum
il faut que les questions soient
précises et que ce ne soit pas pris pour
étant un moyen de valoriser la politique
actuellement en place mais bien pour
interroger les français sur un sujet
particulier merci beaucoup
jean luc fichet je vous laisse regagné
l'hémicycle du sénat où commencer ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
[Musique]
la république portant convocation du
parlement en session extraordinaire à
compter du 1er juillet 2020 a été porté
à connaissance du sénat en conséquence
je constate que la session
extraordinaire est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation et en a
t'il en séance je n'en vois point le
procès verbal est donc adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
c'est avec émotion et tristesse que nous
avons appris la disparition de 25 20 de
notre ancien collègue patrice gélard qui
fut sénateur d'un département cher à
votre coeur monsieur le premier ministre
cdh maritime de 1995 à 2014
diplômé de l'oms au docteur en sciences
politiques et en études slaves agrégé de
droit public patrice gélard fait d'abord
un professeur de droit constitutionnel
passionné qui a marqué des générations
d'étudiants universitaires de renom il
fut doyen de la faculté de droit de
l'université de rouen puis doyen de la
faculté les affaires internationales de
l'université du havre
engagé en politique au rassemblement
pour la république et fut aussi un élu
local profondément ancré dans son
département conseiller municipal du
havre
de 1983 à 2008 conseiller général de
1994 à 2001 adjoint au maire du havre
de 2001 à 2008 vice président de la
communauté d'agglomération du havre
de 2001 à 2014 merde cinq adresses 2008
à 2014 dont peu savent quelle fut la
capitale de la belgique pendant la
première guerre mondiale symbole de
résistance
élu sénateur en 1995 puis réélu en 2004
patrice gélard s'investit fortement dans
sa mission de législateurs et devint
rapidement un pilier de la commission
des lois
il en a été le vice-président en 2001
constitutionnaliste éminent il fut le
rapporteur infatigable de plusieurs
projets de lois constitutionnelles de
multiples projets concernant nos
institutions et de diverses réforme de
notre règlement mais aussi porteur de
grands textes de droit civil rapporteur
de la proposition de loi instaurant le
pacs il fut à l'origine de l'inscription
du concubinage dans le code civil
patrice gélard ne délaisse pas pour
autant les travaux de contrôle il fut le
vice président de l'office d'évaluation
de la législation de 99 à 2004 et
s'illustra par deux rapports remarqué
sur les autorités administratives
indépendantes objet juridique le titre
non identifié grand spécialiste des
institutions l'union soviétique des pays
de l'est
il fut longtemps le président du groupe
d'amitié france russie
d'ailleurs distingué dans l'ordre de
l'amitié russe pour sur l'action de
rapprochement patrice gélard a fait
bénéficier de nos débats de son
exceptionnelle érudition de sa grande
rigueur intellectuelle de son
indéfectible liberté l'esprit de son
remarquable talent d'orateur dans toutes
les langues
d'ailleurs au delà du juriste et de
l'homme politique qui a été une figure
marquante de notre institution c'était
une personnalité pour ceux qui ont
partagé beaucoup avec lui
attachante riche de multiples facettes
qui se consacrait aussi à d'autres
passions peut-être moins connus
l'écriture le dessin la peinture le
théâtre et la collection des soldats de
plantes se souhaite exprimer vraiment
notre sympathie attristée
notre compassion à son épouse
marie-claude à ses enfants sophie
fonctionnaires du sénat
frédéric et véronique et aux membres qui
a hérité rassemblement pour la
république et le groupe l'est
républicain et à tous ceux qui ont
partagé ces engagements vous avez bien
compris
l'affection pour ceux qui l'ont connu
que nous avons partagés autour de
patrice gélard tu apprends les ministres
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci monsieur
le président de m'autoriser à dire un
mot pour saluer le décès de patrice
gélard et il était un sénateur respecté
et estimé dans cette assemblée
il était pour ses amis havre est un
exemple de culture
un exemple d'engagement local à la fois
tranquille est résolue il était aussi un
exemple rare dans la vie politique et je
le dis sans malice car je ne les ai
jamais entendu moi qui ai partagé un
mandat d'adjoint au maire avec lui et
ensuite qui ait siégé dans une
communauté d'agglomération avec les jeux
ne l'est jamais entendu dire du mal
d'aucun autre homme ou femme politique
jamais et c'est assez rare
il était malicieux il était fidèle je
pense à son épouse à ses enfants bien
sûr je pense aussi à son ami antoine
ruffenach il était en classe de 6ème
ensemble et leur vie humaine et
politique s'est déroulée côte-à-côte
mutuellement fait de d'amitié et de
fidélité et je pense aussi à antoine qui
a perdu un ami
et puis il était un universitaire et un
universitaire n'ont pas égaré dans le
monde politique mais un universitaire
qui pensaient que le savoir et la
connaissance devait être aussi un des
fondements de l'action politique
monsieur le président je partage
l'émotion que vous avez formulé je la
partage très vivement et je sais que
samedi à sainte adresse dans l'église
saint denis
nous serons nombreux à lui dire à la
fois notre amitié notre estime et notre
admiration ou s'ils se produisent à lui
observé quelques instants encore bonjour
nous allons associer louis souvet qui
ici fut aussi et partagea avec patrice
gélard ancien sénateur du doubs un homme
très engagé dans le domaine social maire
de montbéliard lui aussi disparu
merci
c'est le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues leur religion rappelle les
questions d'actualité au règlement je
rappelle à chacun le respect des règles
sanitaires
nous devons être vigilants même si nous
avons élargi notre assemblée
chacun doit respecter les distances de
sécurité et j'allais dire les voies
d'entrée et de sortie nous sommes
retransmis sur public sénat et sur notre
site internet et nous respecterons notre
temps la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente sophie primas pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la transition écologique
madame la ministre lundi dernier la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim
c'est arrêter l'énergie nucléaire dont
cette centrale est emblématique a permis
aux français de bénéficier d'une
électricité deux fois moins cher qu'en
allemagne elle a permis à la france de
n'émettre qu'un pour cent des émissions
mondiales de co2 la plaçant très loin
devant son voisin allemand
elle a enfin fortement bénéficié à
l'emploi et à la trique à l'attractivité
de la région alsacienne
la décision de monsieur hollande que
vous mettez en oeuvre aujourd'hui ce
sont près de 2000 emplois locaux qui
vont disparaître sans aucune
concrétisation du plan de reconversion
promis par l'état ce sont 400 millions
d'euros d'indemnités que l'état devra
verser à edf comme l'a cruellement
rappelé la cour des comptes dans un
rapport particulièrement sévère ce sont
six à dix millions de tonnes de co2
supplémentaires par an le repli vers
l'éolien et le solaire ne pouvant
conduire qu'à importer davantage
d'énergies carbonées cet enfant l'exact
inverse de ce que recommande le giec
dans ses derniers rapports qui inclut
quel que soit le scénario retenu une
part significative de nucléaire
madame la ministre la décision que vous
avez prise aura des conséquences
particulièrement négative
cette décision n'est pas économique la
facture énergétique des français et des
entreprises françaises 20 largement
progressé elle n'est pas social vous
pénalisez très fortement tout un bassin
d'emploi est elle née et
évidemment pas écologique vous priver
notre pays d'une énergie décarbonée et
c'est visiblement un avis partagé par
monsieur le ministre ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire alors madame
la ministre pouvait vaut donc nous dire
ce qui a vraiment motivé ce choix pour
vous répondre la parole et à madame la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire madame elisabeth bornes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente
l'arrêt de fessenheim incarne l'écologie
de responsabilité porté par le président
de la république le gouvernement et la
majorité depuis 2010 est avec cette
décision nous tenons nous promesses nous
transformons en profondeur notre modèle
énergétique et nous accompagnons les
français et les territoires dans cette
transformation avec l'arrêt des deux
réacteurs de fessenheim nous engageons
la réduction à 50% de la part du
nucléaire d'ici 2035 tout en
développement massivement les énergies
renouvelables pourquoi parce qu'un
système électrique plus diversifiée est
un système plus résilients et c'est pour
ça que nous allons multiplier par deux
la part de l'éolien et parfums que la
part du photovoltaïque dans les dix ans
mais dans le même temps le gouvernement
et particulièrement vigilant à
l'accompagnement des salariés et des
territoires
s'agissant des salariés d'edf ils seront
tous reclassés au sein du groupe
et s'agissant des salariés des sous
traitants une cellule de reclassement
est en place pour les accompagner
concernant la reconversion du territoire
35 millions d'euros ont déjà été engagés
et il est vrai que la crise a conduit à
prendre du retard dans les mises en
place des différents dispositifs
mais je voudrais souligner l'annoncent
récente du d'un projet d'implantation
d'une usine de biocombustibles qui
pourrait générer 700 emplois dans le
territoire donc soyez assurés madame la
sénatrice que notre politique
énergétique s'inscrit pleinement dans le
respect des accords de paris de l'accord
de paris et que nous accompagnons les
français et les territoires dans la
transition
madame la présidente quelques secondes
oui madame la ministre
vous l'avez dit c'est un c'est un choix
qui est un choix politiciens et
idéologiques et nous attendons vraiment
que l'état déploie une stratégie qui
puisse être à la hauteur du défi posé
par l'arrêt des réacteurs nucléaires et
elle s'était garé je regrette que le
gouvernement ait refusé la feuille de
route que le sénat proposait dans le
cadre de l'examen de la loi énergie
climat qui visait à suivre les
démantèlements à venir comme je regrette
que l' ordonnance relative à
l'accompagnement des fermetures des
centrales à charbon
prévu aussi par cette loi n'est pas été
publiés merci par l'état notre collègue
michèle vullien pour le groupe de
l'union centriste mais la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues comme notre collègue sophie
primas nous avons été frappés par la
fermeture de fessenheim
dans l'actualité récente une fermeture
que nous ne nous expliquons pas la
question de ma collègue aborder
l'ensemble des aspects de la
problématique sociale économique
écologique
ma question portera madame la ministre
plus précisément sur l'articulation
entre cette fermeture est la stratégie
énergétique française
dans l'optique d'atteindre neutralité
carbone en 2050 le nucléaire nous permet
d'être l'un des pays qui émet le moins
de co2 pour sa production d'électricité
et cela garantit notre indépendance ces
mots ne sont pas de moi mais de
ministres bruno le maire
ils sont frappées au coin du bon sens et
pourtant hier le second réacteur de
fessenheim a été déconnecté du réseau
électrique
nous savons que nous ne pourrons pas
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sans décarbonés notre énergie et
nous fermons le central qui justement
produit de l'électricité des cartes
volées à des messages des municipales et
sans ambiguïté nos concitoyens veulent
que la france se verdissent le meilleur
vecteur et bien sûr l'efficacité
énergétique l'énergie la plus décarbonée
est celle que l'on ne consomme pas mais
elle seule l'efficacité énergétique ne
suffira pas vous pourrez viser 50 fois
la constitution mettre en oeuvre toutes
les propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat jamais notre
pays n'atteindra la neutralité carbone
sans le nucléaire malgré les soeurs des
renouvelables
n'oublions jamais que pour atteindre
cette neutralité
il faut plus électricité dans notre mix
énergétique
évidemment de l'électricité propre et
dans l'état actuel de la science
l'électricité renouvelable s'annonce
forcément au nucléaire
nous n'aurons jamais assez d'électricité
renouvelable sans le nucléaire
madame la ministre ne nous dit pas que
l'on peut à la fois produire moins
d'électricité nucléaire et décarbonées
moins d'énergie nucléaire c'est
forcément moins d'électricité propre
donc
de carbone dans l'atmosphère ce que nous
aurions pu faire dans ces conditions
pourquoi avoir fermé face et même si ce
n'est pour des réseaux d'affichage
je vous remercie pour vos réponses la
parole est à la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice du lien moi je comprends qu'on
pose la question de la fermeture de la
centrale de fessenheim et je pense que
c'est important d'expliquer pourquoi
nous le faisons et je peux vous assurer
que ça n'est pas de l'idéologie c'est
vrai que nous devons réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
c'est vrai que l'énergie nucléaire est
décarbonée
mais le nucléaire mais le nucléaire ce
sont aussi des opérations de maintenance
par exemple lourdes et complexes qui
peuvent réduire la disponibilité du parc
et c'est le cas actuellement
suite à la crise sanitaire 50% de notre
parc nucléaire est aujourd'hui à l'arrêt
donc je le redis je suis convaincu qu'un
système électrique plus diversifiée et
plus résilients et puis le nucléaire ce
sont aussi des déchets et c'est donc en
prenant en compte l'ensemble de ces
éléments que nous avons défini la
trajectoire qui figure dans la loi
énergie climat qui n'efface pas le
nucléaire madame la sénatrice qui ramène
la part du nucléaire
keira qui ramène la part du nucléaire à
50% pas 0% 50% en 2035 et je peux vous
assurer que fermer une centrale
nucléaire
ça n'est ni simple ni anodin cette étape
elle est nécessaire pour garantir aux
français une production d'électricité
décarbonée et résiliente
nous avons besoin d'un meilleur
équilibre entre les différentes sources
d'électricité et c'est pour ça que nous
développerons massivement les énergies
renouvelables que nous avons par exemple
augmenter de 20% la production d eau
lien entre 2018 et 2019 que nous voulons
doubler cette production dans les dix
ans et multiplier par cinq la part du du
photovoltaïque
donc moi je suis convaincu que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut mener la transition
écologique et solidaire et énergétique
c'était décisions fortes mais un
accompagnement des français et des
territoires et la parole à notre
collègue françoise cartron pour le
groupe de la république en marche
vous avez la parole votre micro pardon
merci
pas question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire
après neuf mois de travaux la convention
citoyenne pour le climat a présenté ses
travaux
riche de nombreuses propositions c'est
bien ce qu'a souligné le président de la
république aux 150 citoyennes et
citoyens réunis avant-hier à l'elysée
cet exercice de grande ampleur inédite a
été largement salué un travail collectif
de réflexion de délibération qui
participe de ce nouvel élan démocratique
dans notre pays a tant besoin
l'abstention est le même inédite de
dimanche dernier nous le rappelle si
besoin leurs préconisations touche à
tous les domaines de notre vie
quotidienne
promouvoir une alimentation saine et
durable et pas plus tard qu est qu hier
soir dans cet hémicycle nous en
débattions en séance publique mais aussi
développer les transports propres
rénover les bâtiments investir dans
l'industrie les tech nologie de demain
les énergies décarbonées les réseaux et
la préservation de nos ressources en eau
15 milliards d'euros en plus d'ici à
2022 ont d'ailleurs été annoncée pour
réussir cette transition énergétique
la quasi-totalité des mesures adoptées
par la convention devraient être
reprises et trouver une traduction
réglementaire lorsque cela est possible
mais aussi législatives puis
référendaire le président la république
a également rappelé hier que le plan de
relance européen devait être
nécessairement conditionnées à des
engagements climatiques de la part des
états membres
c'est donc un agenda national et
européen
résolument tourné
l'environnement et sa préservation qui
suscite de fortes attentes alors
pourriez vous nous préciser madame la
ministre
l'agenda des travaux qui viendront
mettre en oeuvre cette expression
citoyenne et je pense plus
particulièrement à l'agenda législatif
pour vous répondre la parole et qu'à
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice cartron
alors effectivement le président de la
république s'est exprimé lundi sur les
suites données aux travaux des 150
citoyens qui ont donné de leur temps
personnel pour faire des propositions
fortes pour le climat et je pense que
cela mérite le respect il a fixé un cap
clair et ambitieux et montré que nous
irons au bout de la transformation
écologique de notre pays
d'abord en étant au rendez vous des
attentes de la convention dont il a
repris la quasi totalité des
propositions 146 sur 149 ensuite en
donnant un calendrier précis pour que
ces propositions se transforme en action
donc d'ici la fin du mois un conseil de
défense écologique assurera la mise en
oeuvre des mesures qui relèvent du
gouvernement dès le plan de relance 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires vont
être consacrés à la transition
écologique
enfin un projet de loi sera présenté à
la rentrée pour les mesures qui relèvent
du niveau législatif
ce projet de loi nous allons construire
en concertation avec les élus les
parlementaires et les citoyens de la
convention mon ministère et l'ensemble
du gouvernement est pleinement mobilisée
dans ce sens et comme vous l'avez
rappelé agir au niveau européen est
aussi essentiel
c'est pourquoi le président de la
république porte une reconstruction
économique écologique et solidaire au
plan national comme au plan européen et
les propositions de la convention
citoyenne sont au coeur de ce projet
merci la parole maintenant un autre
collègue ghislaine pop
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole matcher soleil merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre il vous aura suffi d'un tweet
lundi soir pour terrasser le dragon qui
devaient être affectés à la lozère a
lors de la saison estivale obtenu chaque
année de haute lutte par les élus locaux
il vous aura suffi d'un tweet lundi soir
pour appeler un peu plus à la lozère
département ip rural à l'altitude
moyenne la plus haute de france qui lui
est si difficile d'obtenir une
couverture par transport sanitaire
héliporté pourtant garanti à la quasi
totalité des territoires métropolitains
à l'année il vous aura suffi d'un tweet
lundi soir pour plonger les lozériennes
dans le désarroi
eux qui sont aussi rassurés de voir
l'été leur dragon porter assistance aux
personnes et a eu des accidents bloqués
dans des canyons ou en difficulté dans
des zones inaccessibles par la route
monsieur le ministre en lozère les
chances de survie l'internet lors d'un
accident ou d'une maladie ne sont déjà
pas les mêmes que sur le reste du
territoire métropolitain
cela est encore plus insupportable quand
nos routes sont impraticables à cause
des intempéries comme c'est le cas avec
la route nationale 5 6 seul axe routier
majeur désenclavant le sud deux aires
fermé jusqu'à mi juillet au moins alain
bertrand rappelé sur ses banques il ne
peut y avoir de soute et victoire ni de
sous citoyens la lozère ne devrait pas
avoir à quémander un équipement dont les
autres départements sont dotés voir
surdotées nous ne voulons pas bien
évidemment privé l'auvergne de son
dragon et encore moins d'entrer dans une
guerre des territoires à cause de votre
tweet malheureux nous demandons pour cet
été un appareil capable de remplir les
missions que le dragon et à terme les
mêmes missions pardon que le dragon et à
terme des engagements forts du
gouvernement pour mutualiser les
appareils et permettre une couverture de
nos territoires à l'année l'égalité
républicaine et n du pas un caprice
monsieur le ministre quel garantit
pouvez vous nous apportez merci merci
mes chers collègues
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
je voudrais bien évidemment
immédiatement vous rassurer mais je
voudrais qu'on remette les choses dans
le contexte dans lequel nous sommes au
mois de décembre
un hélicoptère de la sécurité civile
s'est accidenté à proximité de
l'aéroport de marignane et je pense à
ces trois personnes qui sont décédées
dans cet accident
au mois de juin notre hélicoptère s'est
accidenté et aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu
heureusement de blessés nous manquons
deux hélicoptères pour la société civile
premier engagement que je prends devant
vous et que si vous votez dans quelques
jours le projet de loi de finances
rectificative porté par gérald darmanin
nous allons pouvoir immédiatement passé
commande de deux nouveaux hélicoptères
je rappelle que la dernière fois
la dernière fois qu'on a parlé
d'hélicoptères pour la sécurité civile
il s'agissait en 2012 de les vendre et
on en a vendu quelques uns
depuis aucun hélicoptère n'a été acheté
nous engageons dans cette procédure
d'achat mais madame la sénatrice ce qui
compte c'est effectivement de pouvoir
garantir la sécurité de nos citoyens et
en particulier dans la lozère et sur la
zone qui est concerné et dont je sais
combien la montée en puissance de la
saison touristique implique la présence
d'hélicoptères
il avait été envisagé de déplacer dragon
63 qui était à clermont ferrand pour le
mettre en lozère mais du coup ça crée
des tensions détention d'intervention
sur la région et sur le territoire de
clermont ferrand et donc j'ai pris la
décision non pas d'empêcher la lozère
d'être équipé mais de faire en sorte que
au même moment ses terres cette semaine
il y ait un hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie nationale qui dispose des
mêmes capacités d'intervention notamment
en matière d'hélitreuillage je sais que
c'est un sujet particulièrement
importante dans votre département qui
sera armé par des gendarmes
professionnels du secours en montagne
avec un hélicoptère qui sera pendant les
deux mois initialement prévu présent sur
la base de monde mais au lieu d'avoir un
hélicoptère de la sécurité
ce sera un hélicoptère de la gendarmerie
madame la sénatrice veut vous garantir
les rues rural que je suis sait
l'importance de ses moyens
d'intervention et la montée en puissance
pendant la saison estivale et donc il y
aura bien un hélicoptère
monde qui sera opérationnel armé par des
gendarmes et qui sera totalement
équipées pour garantir l'ensemble des
interventions nécessaires je vous
remercie
la parole la parole est maintenant notre
collègue pascal savoldelli pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes vous avez la parole
mais merci merci demers merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le président de la
république a pris acte des propositions
formulées par la convention citoyenne
pour le climat j'irai dans un cérémonial
quasi monarchique et comment at on pu
passer d'un exercice de participation
directe à une telle incarnation du
pouvoir et de la décision politique mais
sur le fond et c'est le plus important
le rejet a priori de la proposition d'un
prélèvement annuel à hauteur de 4 % sur
les dividendes des grosses entreprises
envoient un message politique très
claire on touchera au portefeuille de
ceux qui ont le plus de moyens
et pourtant le mouvement des gilet jaune
nous l'a bien montré aucune justice
environnementale ne sera possible sans
justice sociale et donc sans justice
fiscale et refusé un prélèvement de 4 %
des dividendes c'est se priver de deux
milliards d'euros par an et c'est la
cohérence de l'ensemble des 149
proposition qui est remise en cause
condamnant cet exercice à excusez moi
mais une simple opération de
communication est malheureusement dfa
sans lendemain donc monsieur le ministre
pourquoi un tel rejet
quand vous répondre la parole notamment
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur bruno le maire
vous avez la parole oui monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
ce sénateur pour une raison simple c'est
que nous avons déjà fait d'erreur une
fois que nous avons été condamné aussi
bien au niveau national qu'au niveau
européen et qui devait fallu ensuite
récupérer le montant de cette taxe qui
était jugée comme contraire à l'égalité
devant l'impôt et que j'ai été obligé de
présenter devant vous une surtaxe à
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 3% pour
récupérer le montant de cette taxe sur
les dividendes qui avaient été jugées
illégales
nous avons fait l'erreur une fois leur
faisons pas l'erreur
en revanche qu'il faille plus de justice
fiscale mais j'en suis le premier
convaincu qu'il fase et une fiscalité
plus verte et nous sommes tout à fait
prêts à le faire dans le cadre du plan
de relance
mais si vous voulez une fiscalité plus
juste aidez moi monsieur le sénateur je
sais que votre groupe y est prêt à
mettre en place une taxation digitales
non seulement au niveau national mais
aussi au niveau européen vous l'avez
cherché la richesse là où elle se trouve
ce sont les géants du numérique mondiaux
qui ont fait les plus grands profits
pendant cette crise économique c'est eux
qu'il faut les taxer
et c'est cette taxation digital qui sera
juste voulu une taxation verte mais
aidez nous à mettre en place une
taxation carbone aux frontières de
l'union européenne
parce que rien ne sert de décarbonés
notre industrie en france si nous sommes
pas capables de récupérer à l'entrée de
nos frontières
la taxation carbone des produits
importés de l'extérieur
vous voulez une taxation plus juste mais
aidez nous à mettre en place au niveau
européen
la taxation des transactions financières
qui existent en france mais qui n'existe
pas au niveau européen
étendons cette taxe sur les transactions
financières au niveau européen plutôt
que de le faire au niveau national et
enfin voulait une taxation juste mes
démons à lutter contre l'évasion fiscale
et contre l'optimisation fiscale en
mettant en place une taxation minimale à
l'impôt sur les sociétés
comme nous nous battons pour le faire au
niveau international et que nous
arrivons à le faire avec l'allemagne
vous voyez il ya beaucoup de chantiers à
mettre en oeuvre pour avoir une
fiscalité plus juste au niveau
international comme au niveau national
mais je ne pense pas que ce soit en
renouvelant les erreurs du passé
c'est plutôt en inventant la fiscalité
du futur pour vous répondre
non pas pour vous répondre mais roth
monsieur savoldelli oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
comprends bien la difficulté qu est la
vôtre
mais enfin reproché aux élus communistes
écologistes citoyens de paix est à vos
côtés dans l'évasion fiscale c'est un
manque de sérieux
franchement c'est un manque de sérieux
ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose monsieur le ministre
vous et sourire mais l'opinion publique
elle sourit pas on peut pas dire robert
a balayé d'un revers de main il serait
impossible de toucher à 4% les
dividendes
quand on regarde que si dix dernières
années la hausse des dividendes a
augmenté mes chers collègues de 70%
vous connaissez vous quelqu'un un
salarié un paysan vous connaissez
quelqu'un qui ait 70 % d'augmentation
ces dix dernières années donc
franchement c'est pas sérieux
et à chaque fois qu'on vous fait des
propositions que ce soit d'ordre social
ou dordonne vironnement talent on vous
pose la question de répartir qui est un
effort fiscal des plus riches c'est tout
le temps non donc ce que vous êtes en
train de faire c'est une opération de
communication avec du capitalisme vert
et là je vous le dis je vous le dis au
gouvernement je pourrais m'adresser au
président de la république
vous êtes sur un populisme conclure
extrêmement dangereux extrêmement
dangereux merci la parole est à notre
collègue laurence rossignol pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
chers collègues et de droite et de
gauche
c'était le mantra du candidat maquereau
en 2017
le candidat devenu président les
français ont vite constaté qu'en réalité
votre gouvernement s'inspire est plutôt
dû ni de gauche ni de gauche jusqu'au
premier de deuxième tour des élections
municipales ou clairement c'était et de
droite et de droite
tout ça a pu sembler un peu confus aux
français tout ça peut sembler un peu
confus au français mais en revanche le
message qui vous a été envoyé dimanche
dernier est assez clair ceni en marche
ni en marche
car même si les élections intermédiaires
sont souvent difficile pour les
gouvernements en place celle de 2020
sont une cuve est assez spectaculaire
à quelques exceptions près et pas des
moins des gens profitent monsieur le
premier ministre pour saluer de manière
républicaine
votre élection au havre d'autant plus
que la dimension personnelle de cette
élection est probablement importante
donc à quelques étés sont prêts la
majorité ne conquiert aucune ville
importante et même mêmes pères des
villes qu'elle avait obtenu auparavant
grâce à des transfuges souvent
d'ailleurs dans nos propres rangs
je pense à lyon je pense à besançon je
pense à strasbourg et même dans mon
département c'est arrivé et sans parler
bien sûr des échecs de vos ministres qui
comptait bien faire main basse sur la
ville de paris et qui chacun sait ont
eux aussi échoué et le taux d'abstention
inédit malgré vos promesses de
réconcilier les français la démocratie
ne relativise pas pour autant la clarté
du message qui a été adressé au
président de la république à sa majorité
monsieur le premier ministre en campagne
aux arbres vous avez dit aux havrais que
vous reviendriez en 2022
ma question est simple souhaitez vous
continuer à diriger la france et avec
quelles orientations politiques
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement
je marc fesneau merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
j'avais l'air déçu d'abord d'abord je
voudrais saluer toutes celles et ceux
qui ont décidé au saut à ces élections
municipales comme à toutes les élections
de défendre leurs idées parce que y'a
rien de plus sain et plus honorable en
démocratie que défendre ses idées je
pense qu'on devrait saluer toutes celles
et ceux qui ont fait le choix de
s'engager ceux qui ont gagné et puis
ceux qui ont perdu parce que ça fait
partie de la que les démocraties que
gagner ou de perdre la deuxième chose
qui devrait nous alerter
vous avez assez peu parlé cette chose
c'est la question de l'abstention je
pense qu'à nous elle devrait ça n'était
pas la partie la plus longue
c'est une question qui est importante
pour nous de voir au fond on sait que le
mandat de maire est sûre le 8 le maire
et celui sans doute l'élu le plus aimé
et dans cette élection c'est l'élection
google+ d'abstention et je pense que ça
doit nous interroger
la troisième chose vous avez l'air de
vouloir en faire un test national or si
c'est un test national je voudrais
saluer les victoires de gérald darmanin
à tourcoing et d'edouard philippe au
havre je n'ose parler de ma propre
élection dans ma commune
messi soit c'est un test national soit
c'est une élection locale et l'équation
personnelle compte d'ailleurs vous
l'avez dit vous-même
auquel cas faisant un an plus tôt il est
quoi une élection locale
la troisième chose que je voudrais vous
dire les élections par part comment
dirais-je habitudes et et expériences
s'invite à la fois à la modestie à la
lucidité
vous avez comme moi gagné et perdu des
élections vous avez perdu des élections
97 en 2002 et en 2007
moi aussi j'ai perdu des élections
locales nous avons perdu des élections
nationales
vous aussi et moi aussi et donc ça
devrait nous inviter à la modestie parce
que parfois ce qui paraît des victoires
n'en ai pas et parfois quand on perd on
n'a pas les éclés la nécessité lucidité
dont je pense qu'il faut faire c'est
travail de lucidité la troisième chose
que je voudrais vous dire madame la
sénatrice
il ya des résultats il ya des résultats
variables d'un département à l'autre
parce que l'équation locale a compté
vous savez comme moi la seule chose
hélas ionisants ce qu'on doit avoir
parce que c'est l'engagement que nous
avons tous comme élus nationaux et
locaux
cette pré faire prévaloir les et
l'intérêt national l'intérêt local et au
fond maintenant il ya des élus on doit
sont félicités c'est avec eux qu'on doit
travailler pour faire en sorte qu'on
fasse avancer le pays
nombreux et nous pourrons les relever
ensemble la parole est maintenant notre
collègue daniel chassaing pour le groupe
les indépendants vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre finances mes chers collègues la
crise économique frappe le secteur
automobile le gouvernement a déjà
annoncé un plan conjuguant relance
économique et transition écologique
malgré tout de nombreuses suppressions
d'emploi arrivent je vais parler de la
corrèze où nous apprenions brutalement
le 25 juin dernier une très mauvaise
nouvelle l'entreprise borgwarner qui
emploie 3 168 salariés a annoncé la
fermeture de son usine en 2022 bon goût
amer a racheté l'entreprise séculaire de
tud en 1995 avant de la transférer sa
production sur une zone industrielle
réalisé par le conseil départemental
en 2005 plusieurs années près de 700 tr
derniers ont travaillé dans l'entreprise
pour la fabrication de boîtes à vitesses
à double embrayage process abandonnés
dans les voitures électriques 95% de la
production est destinée aux marques
volkswagen audi
malgré les alertes réitéré des syndicats
la direction n'a pas souhaité enclenché
diversification préparant la décoller la
délocalisation de l'entreprise
après la tristesse des employés des
familles et des élus devant cette
catastrophe économique les élus du
bassin de tulle parlementaire le
président pascal costes et mon collègue
claude nougein viennent aujourd'hui par
ma voix vous demander d'aider la corrèze
et se basent-ils sinistrées afin de
trouver ensemble une solution de reprise
du site et de ses employés
la transition écologique devrait-on
devrait dit-on entraîné le développement
de nouvelles productions
cette entreprise avait été créée en 1895
pour produire des cycles mais
aujourd'hui nous ne produisons en france
que 700 mille vélos par an soit un quart
de notre consommation contre deux
millions en allemagne en italie et même
au portugal
dans ce contexte ma raison ma question
est simple monsieur le ministre des
finances comment pensez vous assurer une
transition écologique véritablement
solidaire qui ne s'acquittent sacrifie
pas les emplois
permettre la survie de cette entreprises
corréziennes merci pour vos réponses de
la parole était aux ministres de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
maire et monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs de
sociétaires chassaing la transition
écologique c'est une nécessité absolue
je pense que tout le monde ici en est
convaincu mais nous fait face à un défi
absolument considérable c'est
d'accompagner cette transition
écologique une transition des emplois et
d'une transition industrielle et site de
borg warner à tulle je pourrais en citer
d'autres d'autres sites industriels liés
à l'automobile qui produisent des
injecteurs diesel des pièces pour les
véhicules thermiques en est une
illustration parfaite
ces 3 168 emplois c'est le premier site
industriel de corrèze et j'ai eu
l'occasion d'appeler le président de
corrèze pascal costes pour lui en parler
et c'est un drame pour la ville de tulle
c'est un drame aussi pour d'autres
bassins d'emploi je pense en particulier
à la vallée de l'arve à tous les
décolleteurs à tous ceux qui produisait
des pièces pour borg warner à tulle donc
il ya un effet de chaîne un effet de
cascade sur l'emploi lié à cette
transition écologique et au passage du
moteur thermique au moteur électrique
qui nous oblige à trouver des solutions
innovantes
est ce que c'est la solution c'est de
préserver à tout prix
tous les emplois liés au moteur
thermique certainement pas c'est
l'assurance d'un drame social économique
encore plus important à une vitesse que
personne ne mesure ici en revanche la
bonne solution c'est celle qui vise à
trouver d'autres possibilités industriel
c'est celle qui vise à diversifier ses
sites industriels à former à qualifier
des salariés et donc je demande à bord
verner dans l'es2 gens qu'ils ont devant
eux de faire tout le nécessaire pour
accompagner chaque salarié et je prends
l'engagement devant vous qu'avec les
élus locaux avec le président du
département
nous ferons tous je dis bien tout pour
trouver des solutions industrielles
innovantes qui permettront de garantir
pas dans le véhicule thermique mais sur
d'autres activités industrielles
un avenir industriel à ce site à tulle
en corrèze
merci la parole de notre collègue pierre
charon pour le groupe l'est républicain
président ce premier ministre mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la garde des sceaux
la semaine dernière un journal révélait
que pendant plusieurs années les
portables des avocats de renom ont été
surveillés dans le cadre d'une enquête
préliminaire ordonnée par le parquet
national financiers cette enquête
décidée pour une prétendue violation du
secret professionnel a été ordonné alors
que quelques jours avant
une information judiciaire avait été
ouverte le 26 février 2014 sur des faits
connexes
malgré l'absence de preuves le pnf a
relancé cette enquête en octobre 2016
sans succès non plus en décembre 2019
un classement sans suite pour infraction
insuffisamment caractérisée et même
prononcé les conditions de cette enquête
sont troublantes 1 après s'étaient
jointes au reste de la procédure pendant
longtemps et ces résultats ont été caché
à la défense le pnf agit comme une
juridiction d'exception qui nous
rappellent les pires errements du
justice livrée à elle-même l'autorité
judiciaire ne saurait être hors contrôle
veiller à l'intégrité des comptes
publics ou privés est une chose régler
des comptes avec les hommes politiques
en est une autre
la cour rend d arrêt et non pas des
services disait un grand magistrat du
19e siècle
cette imbrication malsaine du bnf dans
le jeu politique nous a même valu il ya
trois ans une élection présidentielle
insolite où le favori n'a même pas été
qualifié pour le second tour
à la suite de propos tenus par l'ancien
procureur du bénef
le président de la république a saisi le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
et vous madame avait demandé timidement
un rapport circonstancié sur la nature
précise de l'enquète du pmf il était
temps de saisir l'inspection générale
tout à l'heure de la justice car c'est
l'existence même du plein air qui pose
problème
madame la garde des sceaux qu'entendez
vous faire face à cette crise de
confiance de la justice après que le mur
deco ne soit pas suivie par le mur de la
honte
bon on va répandre la parole et à madame
le garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur charron
je comprends l'émotion qu'a suscitée les
propos de madame me et boulettes
lorsqu'elle a répondu à la commission
denquête devant l'assemblée nationale
et vous l'avez rappelez-vous mail le
président de la république est le garant
de l'indépendance de l'autorité
judiciaire a sollicité un avis du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
j'ai partagé vraiment les mois de et les
interrogations liées aux révélations
faites par l'hebdomadaire le point et
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
demandé non pas timidement j'ai demandé
un rapport madame la procureure générale
de paris qui me l'a rendu hier soir au
vu de ce rapport j'ai donc immédiatement
décidé de saisir l'inspection générale
de la justice afin que l'inspection
puisse déterminer l'étendue et la
proportionnalité des actes
d'investigation ainsi que le cadre
procédural de l'enquète qui a été
effectué pour autant monsieur le
sénateur je crois qu'il est important de
ne pas faire d'amalgamé
je voudrais de ce point de vue
simplement redire trois choses s'il ya
des dysfonctionnements qui sont révélés
par l'inspection générale de la justice
il faudra aller reconnaître
pour autant je crois que le parquet
national financier est une institution
qui est la garante de la souveraineté
judiciaire de notre pays et nous le
voyons dans des dossiers tels que hsbc
tels que google os et dans ce cadre là
le pnf a vraiment montrer sa
reconnaissance internationale son
expertises sa compétence je dirai
ensuite et c'est le deuxième point que
dans aucune affaire
le gouvernement n'a donné d'instruction
individuelle a aucun magistrat
et c'est important à redire parce que
c'est le gage de la confiance que les
français doivent avoir dans la justice
donnant des instructions générales parce
que c'est la structuration et
hiérarchique du parquet à la française
qui nous y autorise mais pas
d'instruction individuelle est ma
troisième observation sera pour dit
dire que des réponses adaptées à ces
situations seront apportées par ce qui
manque l'essentiel de ne pas laisser le
doute s'installer
parce que j'ai confiance comme vous dans
la justice française que charon vous
avez quelques secondes la parole m notre
collègue jean luc fichet pour le trouve
juste envie que ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre le
président de la république recevait
lundi les 150 membres de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat notre groupe
tient à saluer la qualité des travaux
menés par ce panel de citoyens qui se
sont engagés en faveur d'une transition
écologique ambitieuse pour notre pays le
chef de l'état indiqué reprendre 146e
des 149 propositions formulées en
voulant je cite les transmettent sans
filtre au parlement pour ce qui relève
de la loi un texte multi mesure est
ainsi annoncée pour la rentrée nous
aurions besoin d'éclaircissements sur ce
point surtout de l'assurance qu'il sera
bien accompagné des financements
nécessaires sur le court terme et pas
seulement dans un cadre pluriannuel sur
le sujet par exemple de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation durable qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur des enjeux
économiques sont en effet indissociable
des enjeux environnementaux
il faut renforcer la lutte contre les
inégalités sociales face à
l'alimentation et les agriculteurs
doivent être accompagnés dans la
transition agro écologiques en termes
d'aidé financière mais aussi de
formation sans un engagement résolu de
l'état en la matière les propositions
formulées risque sinon de rester lettre
morte
il faut maintenir des usines partout sur
le territoire ne pas concentrer celle ci
dans les métropoles les mieux desservis
je cite le président l'aqueduc le 29
juin lors de la convention citoyenne
parallèlement ou en même temps à morlaix
dans le finistère
air france hop informe de la fermeture
du site de maintenance aéronautique de
276 emploi mais sur le premier ministre
comment pouvez vous agir et il est
encore temps pour éviter un tel désastre
dans des territoires en difficulté et
être véritablement en cohérence avec les
engagements de la convention citoyenne
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est madame la ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur alors comme vous
l'avez dit le président de la république
a reçu lundi les 150 citoyens et il a
été au rendez vous des propositions de
la convention en reprenant la
quasi-totalité 146 sur 149 des
propositions de la convention
au-delà de cet engagement ce sont bien
sûr des calendrier précis qui ont été
annoncées par le président de la
république avec à la fois un conseil de
défense écologique d'ici la fin du mois
pour prendre les mesures qui relèvent du
niveau réglementaire donc du
gouvernement s'est aussi 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour accélérer
la transition écologique qui seront
intégrées dans le plan de relance et je
pense que ça vaut répond je l'espère à
votre question
effectivement cette transition
écologique elle mérite des soutiens
financiers
que ce soit pour accélérer la transition
du modèle agricole pour accélérer la
rénovation des passoires thermiques et
des bâtiments que ce soit pour accélérer
les investissements dans le transport
ferroviaire ces investissements ils
seront nécessaires et ses 15 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires et ils seront
bien intégré au plan de relance
et puis au delà un projet de loi
effectivement spécifique sera présenté à
la rentrée un projet de loi que nous
allons naturellement élaboré en
concertation avec les élus avec les
parlementaires avec les citoyens bien
entendu et je partage ce que vous dite
évidemment cette transition écologique
elle entraîne des transformations
profondes dans les territoires cette
transition écologique elle doit
embarquer l'ensemble des français
l'ensemble des territoires
et c'est bien le sens de la transition
écologique et solidaire que nous voulons
mener
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue jean sol pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
le président merci ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre des solidarités
de la santé le secteur de la santé tout
particulièrement l'hôpital public en
face à des difficultés majeures depuis
des années nous avons légitimement cru
après les grèves des urgences et la
démission des chefs de service
hospitaliers la colère des ehpad mais
surtout après cette terrible crise
sanitaire durant laquelle tous nos
soignants ont été au front jour et nuit
que vous les aviez zanfer entendu et que
les problèmes les plus urgents notamment
les dégradations des conditions de
travail et les rémunérations
insuffisantes allait enfin être prises
en considération
or il n'allait toujours rien aujourd'hui
le secure de la santé n'y réponds pas
messieurs les ministres
car nos soignants sont de nouveau dans
la rue ces mêmes soignants qui ont
risqué parfois perdu la vie on nous
sortir de la cofidis 9
ces mêmes soignant que nous
applaudissons tous les soirs à la même
heure pour les remercier de leur
dévouement et de leur engagement
ces mêmes soignants qui sont en droit
d'attendre mieux et plus que des
médailles ou de quelques primes les
faits et les chiffres sont là
en france nos médecins hospitaliers sont
payés 40 % de moins que leurs collègues
allemands nos infirmiers com nous aide
soignants sont rémunérés 20% de moins
que leurs homologues européens mais cela
va encore plus loin
l'administration a submergé la santé en
france et tout particulièrement
l'hôpital où le personnel soignant mais
sachant a depuis longtemps perdu tout
pouvoir
oui ou 9 km en notre système de santé
actuel est d'abord malades de la sueur
administration il ya urgence à repenser
toute l'organisation du travail des
services publics de santé
les charges administratives ne doivent
pas entacher leur quotidien la
gouvernance des hôpitaux reconsidérer
les moyens humains et logistiques
adaptés
le management et la formation améliorée
vous allez me répondre qu'au travers du
ségur de la santé vous venez d'annoncer
des revalorisations
ces dernières ne répondent pas aux
attentes légitimes des professionnels de
santé qui n'ont pas de mots assez forts
pour critiquer ce qui n'est toujours que
du saupoudrage
pourquoi monsieur le ministre le ségur
de la santé utiles les problèmes de
gouvernance à l'hôpital
pourquoi renoncer à dégraisser le
mammouth administratif enfin qu'attendez
vous pour remplacer votre plan de
communication par une vraie réforme en
profondeur pour la parole et à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de santé valable du gosse
avait la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean sol vous interroger le
gouvernement sur les concertations qui
se tiennent sur le ségur de la santé les
objectifs est annoncé partant par le
premier ministre que par le ministre
sont claires et ferons nous ferons tout
pour qu'ils soient tenus
vous avez rappelé les constats et c'est
face à ces constats que nous avons porté
quatre piliers dans le cadre du ségur de
la santé le premier est bien de
revaloriser la rémunération les cas les
carrières des soignants le gouvernement
et vous l'avez dit est prêt à mettre 6
milliards d'euros par an sur la table
pour restaurer l'attractivité de nos
métiers et améliorer la qualité des
soins
cela a été présenté il ya quelques jours
aux partenaires sociaux les
représentants de personnels médicaux
les paramédicaux les internes et les
étudiants ces derniers jours le deuxième
objectif est de travailler à une relance
de l'investissement et à de nouveaux
modèles de financement
la reprise du tiers de la dette des
hôpitaux dont vous débattre et cet
après-midi représente un effort de 13
milliards de roubles pour la nation et
dans le cadre du ségur de la santé nous
discutons également d'un nouveau plan
d'investissement pour les établissements
de santé les ehpad et le numérique en
santé le troisième objectif rendre plus
souple plus simple notre système dont la
gouvernance parce que les soignants
doivent soigner ne doivent pas crouler
sous l'administration
et c'est bien là le coeur du sujet de ce
troisième pilier enfin le quatrième
objectif c'est mettre en place des
organisations plus proche des
territoires plus collective entre
l'hôpital la médecine de ville et le
secteur médico-social ses pensées
l'accès aux soins au plus près des
territoires et faire en sorte que tous
les professionnels travaillent ensemble
c'est bien ceci notre boussole
nous sommes vous nous dites que ça prend
du temps nous sommes donné 50 jours les
négociations sont encore en cours
actuellement le ministre de la santé est
avec l'ensemble des représentants et
partenaires sociaux pour continuer à
discuter et
quelques jours les annonceurs en fait je
vous remercie merci la parole et à
d'autres collègues olivier cadic pour le
groupe de l'union centriste avait la
parole monsieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des armées le sommet
g5 celle qui s'est tenue hier à
nouakchott s'inscrit dans la suite du
sommet de pau voulu il ya six mois par
le président de la république pour
refonder notre action au sahel
cette rencontre avait permis d'établir
deux objectifs pour gagner cette guerre
d'abord combattre les terroristes
ensuite former et équiper les armées
nationales
n'oublions jamais que chaque jour nos
soldats livre un âpre combat contre les
djihadistes dans le sahel 41 militaires
français y ont fait le sacrifice de leur
vie depuis 2013 depuis pau des succès
spectaculaires ont été atteints par nos
forces armées
ils font notre fierté et notre groupe
veut leur témoigner toute notre
gratitude la mobilisation européenne à
nos côtés se confirme même si elle reste
encore trop lente
la task force takouba est à cet égard
aussi importante que représentative
madame la ministre l'estonie sera-t-il
le seul pays européen à nous rejoindre
mais après avoir gagné la guerre le plus
dur est souvent de gagner la paix vous
l'avez dit vous-même madame la ministre
une opération tels que bach cannes n'a
pas vocation à être pérenne l'action
militaire n'est pas une fin en soi mais
un moyen au service d'un objectif global
qui a motivé notre présence permettre à
des états de demeurer libre et de
fonctionner normalement de manière
indépendante au service de leur
population
c'est pourquoi deux objectifs avaient
été fixés à pau pour gagner la paix le
retour des états dans les territoires
ravagé par le djihadisme l'aide au
développement de la région cependant le
président de la république la nuit lui
même à son arrivée à nouakchott
hier il faut en faire davantage dans ce
domaine
ma question est donc simple où on l
alliance sahel et sommes nous sur la
bonne voie je vous remercie plein pour
vous répondre la parole qu'à madame le
ministre désormais madame florence par
les ailes de l'appareil
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur au sel nous avons trois mots
d'ordre
le premier c'est la détermination
le second c'est la coopération et le
troisième c'est la complémentarité
alors oui nous sommes déterminés à
continuer à lutter contre le terrorisme
dans cette région
et c'est grâce à la détermination du
président de la république qui en
lançant le sommet de pau a créé cet élan
qui nous a permis tous ensemble de
rencontres de remporter et d'engranger
des succès notamment militaire et de
donner un nouvel élan à notre action ce
nouvel élan s'est en effet celui de la
coopération carrousel la victoire est
possible si nous restons unis et sous ni
si nous unissons nos forces avec les
pays du g5 sahel et aussi avec les
européens et il faut le faire pour
accompagner au combat les forces armées
locales les forces armées chiliennes se
sont remobilisés c'est visible des camps
militaires ont été repris et le niveau
de coopération s'est grandement
améliorée vous l'avez souligné la task
force takouba va pouvoir démarrer dans
quelques jours avec des forces spéciales
françaises estonienne dans un premier
temps qui seront rejointes par des
forces spéciales tchèque puis suédoise
peut-être italienne les grecs également
sont en train d'examiner la question de
leur participation et je voudrais quand
même souligner une chose c'est que en
général les processus européen sont
lents et bien en moins d'un an ce sont
treize pays dont onze européens qui
auront contribué à construire cette
force
enfin dernière condition de succès c'est
la complémentarité et là c'est vrai
l'action militaire n'est pas une fin en
soi il faut pouvoir aider les pays du
sahel à faire face à ces défis
sécuritaires économiques et sociaux et
c'est pourquoi sur le terrain les
militaires de barkan contribuer à
accompagner le retour de l'état comme
ils l'ont fait encore récemment à la bge
en ga et oui les populations reviennent
alors bien sûr il faudra faire plus mais
les premiers signaux sont là nous sommes
dans la bonne voie
ce qu'elle dit
un homme est ministre nous sommes unis à
vos côtés pour gagner cette guerre
continuez sur cette voie collective et
l'europe fera la preuve au monde qu'elle
est bien une force de paix je remercie
la parole et à notre collègue jacky
d'euromédis pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre les conséquences de la double
crise sanitaire économique affecte
considérablement un grand nombre de
français résidant hors de france le 30
avril dernier nous a été présenté un
dispositif de soutien aux français de
l'étranger
le 220 millions d'euros auxquels
viennent de s'ajouter 35 millions c'est
mieux mais cela reste malheureusement
très insuffisant j'ai conscience de la
difficulté pour le budget de l'état
d'ouvrir des aides aux français de
l'étranger mais nous n'avons pas le
choix
la france n'a pas le droit d'abandonner
ses enfants où qu'ils soient
il s'agit là d'un appel au secours de
personnes qui ont jamais tendu la main
mais qu'il faut soutenir pour quelques
mois
il faut un plan d'urgence à la hauteur
de la situation
il doit inclure outre l'aide sociale est
le soutien à l'enseignement français le
soutien aux entrepreneurs
certains d'entre eux connaissent de
graves difficultés financières en
particulier dans les secteurs impactées
directement par la crise il contribue
aussi au développement économique de la
france mais ne bénéficie pas la plupart
du temps des deux dans leur pays
d'accueil
comment accueillir et vous les familles
ou les retraités qui n'arrivent plus à
vivre à l'étranger ce que les familles
ne peuvent pas prendre en charge
ne pensez vous pas que cela coûtera plus
cher si vous devez les rapatrier les
loger leur permettent de trouver un
travail de scolariser leurs enfants
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'europe des affaires étrangères jean
baptiste lemoyne vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
sénatrice madame la sénatrice jacky
dermé dit je veux saluer vraiment tous
les conseillers des français de
l'étranger
les parlementaires représentant les
français établis hors de france nos
postes au sein des consulats des
ambassades qui sont mobilisés depuis le
début de la crise pour apporter aide
soutien appuyé et bien à nos
compatriotes effectivement à ces trois
millions et demi de français établis
hors de france et qui ont été les
premiers en fait à être touchés on se
souvient notamment du mois de janvier à
wuhan lorsque nous avons dû procéder à
un certain nombre d'évacuations de nos
ressortissants et qui continuent alors
même que en france et bien nous avons
endiguer l'épidémie nous ont fait
reculer dans d'autres pays à les toucher
c'est pourquoi le 30 avril dernier avec
jean yves le drian avec gérald darmanin
nous avons effectivement présenté ce
plan d'action massif en appui à nos
compatriotes 220 millions d'euros vous
l'avez dit avec 20 millions d'euros sur
le volet sanitaire
ça veut dire que très concrètement il ya
dans 81 pays des plans sanitaires qui
ont été établis avec de la
téléconsultation 4 tonnes de médicaments
préacheminer pour faire face à
d'éventuelles ruptures de stock dans le
système commercial local et un système
d'évacuations sanitaires disponibles h
24 7 jours sur 7 trois avions qui ont
une capacité à ces évacuations 18 de nos
compatriotes
on a d'ores et déjà bénéficié le volet
social avec 50 millions d'euros et je
veux redire ici des chiffres que j'ai
évoqué hier lors de la discussion de la
proposition de loi relative à la
création d'un fonds d'urgence
proposition de loi que je salue portée
par le sénateur le bleu adopté à
l'unanimité
nous avons fait je crois du bon travail
hier et est bien 2727 français ont
bénéficié de ces aides sociales pour 390
mille euros et on voit bien que au
regard des crédits qu'on a mis en place
eh bien il ya encore le la capacité pour
faire face et notamment je souhaite
travailler effectivement sur un volet
complémentaire relatifs aux
entrepreneurs parce que certains n'ont
pas dead locale c'est un dossier
nous sommes en train de travailler avec
nos collègues de bercy donc continuer
ensemble et nous serons toujours à leurs
côtés bien sûr l'homme dormait dit oui
merci monsieur le ministre il y à 65
millions de français pour lesquels on a
débloqué 500 milliards et il y a trois
millions et demi de français expatriés
pour lesquels ont débloqué 255 millions
c'est-à-dire 10% de ce qu'on donne aux
français dans l'hexagone c'est pas la
même chose je suis d'accord les français
résidant hors de france ne souhaite pas
rentrer si vous leur donner la
possibilité de rester dans leur pays
d'accueil il s'agit de les aider pour
quelques mois où il faudra les rapatrier
dans des conditions qui ne feront pas
honneur à la cinquième puissance
mondiale et la parole est à notre
collègue xavier iacovelli pour le groupe
de la république en marche de la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre de l'économie chers collègues
avec plus de 3 millions d'entreprises le
commerce de proximité l'artisanat et les
indépendants représentent une part
majeure de l'économie française
ils sont pour nos territoires et nos
concitoyens qui vivent source de lien
social et de richesses
nos commerces constituent des lieux des
chances qui contribue à l'attractivité
et au dynamisme de nos communes en étant
au plus près des attentes de consignes
de nos concitoyens et en leur offrant
des produits et de services de qualité
ils sont en quelque sorte l'âme de nos
territoires
mais aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
nos commerçants artisans et indépendants
souffrent ils s'ouvrent car avec la
crise sanitaire que nous avons traversée
qui frappe notre pays bon nombre d'entre
eux furent privés de toute activité
pendant près de trois mois
malgré les aides dont ils ont bénéficié
beaucoup craignent de ne pas pouvoir se
relever déjà fragilisées par la crise
des gilets jaunes et des autres
mouvements sociaux que nous avons eu
dernièrement il souffre car nous le
savons
l'activité économique est bien loin de
retrouver son niveau d'avant crise et le
retour à la normale sera très long il ya
des jours monsieur le ministre vous avez
annoncé un plan de soutien à hauteur de
900 millions d'euros pour aider les
commerçants artisans et indépendants
il prolonge ainsi les dispositifs
existants je pense notamment à
l'activité partielle au fonds de
solidarité auprès de garantie par l'état
et au report des charges fiscales et
sociales
ce plan qui a pour objectif de renforcer
leur trésorerie constituent une
réponse concrète aux attentes de nos
commerçants artisans et indépendants
dont le chiffre d'affaires a déjà
considérablement baissé la
redynamisation du commerce de proximité
est une exigence pour nos centres villes
et centres bourgs cher à nos collègues
pointereau et bourquin il s'agit d'un
gage d'attractivité pour nos territoires
est une véritable richesse pour nos
concitoyens qui vivent ma question
monsieur le ministre pouvait vous ici
nous apporter plus de précisions quant à
ce plan qui permettra je l'espère de
répondre à ce secteur qui est gravement
touché merci répondre
la parole est aux ministres de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
maire je vous rejoins totalement
monsieur le sénateur je considère que
les commerçants les artisans les
indépendants sont probablement ceux qui
ont le plus souffert de ces mois de
crise tout simplement parce qu'ils
étaient fermés qu'ils ont vu leur
chiffre d'affaires baisser de 50 60 80 %
et qu'il avait absolument aucune
solution disponible
c'est pour ça qu'avec le premier
ministre avec le ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics
nous avons déployé toute une série
d'instruments très puissant le fonds de
solidarité
les exonérations les reports de charges
sociales et fiscales le chômage partiel
tout ce qu'il aura permis de te passer
ces quatre mois de crise avec le moins
de dégâts possibles maintenant nous
voulons faire plus nous voulons faire
plus pour revitaliser un certain nombre
de centres bourg de centre ville et pour
aider les commerçants indépendants et
artisans dans les mois qui viennent tu
as beau nous allons prendre des mesures
nouvelles de trésorerie parce que c'est
là dessus que la tente est la plus forte
nous allons supprimer c'est une
habitante de longue date des
indépendants la majoration de 25% pour
les indépendants et commerçants qui
n'adhèrent pas à un organisme de gestion
agréé cela fait des années qu'ils le
demandent nous allons le faire
nous allons prolonger le fonds de
solidarité
le fonds solidarité sera prolongée au
mois de juin pour l'enchantent artisans
commerçants et indépendants qui sont
éligibles
enfin nous allons leur permettre de
débloquer des contrats madelin hauteur
de 8000 euros dont 2000 euros seront
défiscalisées ce sont les mesures de
trésorerie
deuxième série de mesures
totalement nouvelle la création de 100
foncière qui vont pouvoir partout sur le
territoire
rachetée 6000 fonds de commerce les
rénover énergétiquement et les louer à
tarif préférentiel pour que des
commerces nouveau s'installe dans les
centres villes dans les centres bourgs
et dans les communes de taille moyenne
c'est un dispositif totalement nouveau
efficace qui permettra d'avoir des
commerces qui rouvre dans des centres
villes et dans les communes rurales
enfin troisième dispositif nous allons
engager un plan de numérisation et de
digitalisation de tous les commerces
parce que la crise a montré que ce
qu'était digitalisées s'en sortent des
mieux vous voyez nous avons fait
beaucoup
nous ferons encore plus pour les
indépendants les commerçants la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue henri
leroy pour le groupe l'est républicain
vosges avait la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre il y à
paris la police a procédé à des
contrôles d'identité
tout s'est bien passé les citoyens
avaient leurs documents d'identité
ils étaient ni arrogant ni irrespectueux
ils n'ont pas tenté de fuir
aucun d'entre eux n'étaient recherchés
il n'y a eu aucun esclandre les
policiers n'ont pas été filmée ni
insulter ils ont été courtois et poli
comme ils le sont toujours dans
l'exercice de leurs nombreuses missions
au contact bravo au temps pourtant la
police manque cruellement de moyens
matériels d'équipements techniques leur
véhicule insuffisants sont usés
l'information incomplète leur leproux
vétustes parfois insalubres leur moral
au plus bas ils se sentent abandonnés
peu soutenu ni écouté ni compris bref
ils sont en grande souffrance ces
policiers comme nous n'avons cessé de le
souligner depuis trois ans avec force
dans nos rapports sénatoriaux sur les
programmes 176 et 152 des projets de loi
de finance par les commissions des
finances et des lois mais sur surtout
dans le rapport de la commission d'
enquête sur l'état des forces de
sécurité que nous vous avons remis 20
tout y est dit sans résultat concret en
réponse notre édifice sécuritaire craque
de toutes parts cependant monsieur le
premier ministre
nos forces de l'ordre continuent à
produire un travail constant remarquable
en étant à bout de souffle et ce n'est
pas loin de là un mouvement d'humeur
lorsque l'un des piliers de l'ordre va
si la santé de la république et bien en
danger
ma question est simple très simple après
le figure de la santé à quand le
bourreau de la sécurité le livre blanc
annoncée et déjà obsolète
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mais la
messe internationale sénateur leroy
d'abord comme vous je veux saluer
l'engagement constant de nos forces de
sécurité
confronté quelquefois des difficultés
mais très généralement comme vous l'avez
indiqué à paris et partout en france à
des citoyens qui savent ce qu'ils
doivent dans leurs capacités
d'intervention à nos forces de sécurité
intérieure avec des citoyens qui savent
aussi ce qu'ils doivent le respect à nos
forces de sécurité intérieure et cela
monsieur le sénateur nous livrons
partout sur le territoire national média
détention il ya des tensions qui
augmente et notamment les violences
contre les policiers pas seulement en
france
j'ai changé la semaine dernière avec le
ministre allemand de l'intérieur
seehofer en allemagne l'année dernière
les violences contre les policiers ont
augmenté de 2 et les gendarmes
correspondant à l'organisation
spécifique de l'allemagne ont augmenté
de 46%
voilà la réalité face à laquelle nous
devons faire face le livre blanc la
sécurité intérieure doit permettre à
partir de l'ensemble des constats de
définir cette nouvelle sécurité à
hauteur d'homme au coeur desquelles des
femmes les hommes de la police de la
gendarmerie de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure doivent être les acteurs et
pour cela nous devons effectivement les
équipes et nous devons les protéger
nous avons lancé vous le savez monsieur
sénateurs un plan de recrutement de dix
mille policiers et gendarmes et nous
aboutirons à la fin du quinquennat par
ce renforcement là nous avons décidé
aussi d'augmenter très fortement le
budget de la sécurité intérieure plus
10% depuis le début de ce quinquennat
c'est plus de 1 milliard d'euros
est ce que cela suffit la réponse est
non nous devons bien évidemment renforcé
encore mais pas seulement de façon
budgétaires y compris dans son
organisation
compris dans les moyens de défense au
quotidien de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure leur protection naturelle
pour qu'il puisse agir au mieux
nous avons ouvert des chantiers que nous
n'avons pas regardé depuis de trop
nombreuses années notamment le paiement
des heures supplémentaires certaines
étaient dus depuis 2005 et l'année
dernière pour la première fois nous
avons commencé à payer cette dette mais
nous devons apporter d'autres réponses y
compris de protection fonctionnelle que
nous devons garantir à cela et de
protection au quotidien notamment avec
le développement massif des caméras
piétons autant d'outils qui trouvent
toute leur place dans le livre blanc que
vous avez évoquées et qu'il ne faudra
collectivement mettre en oeuvre monsieur
le sénateur merci la parole et à notre
collègue marie noëlle suler pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain
je salue cette première prise de parole
dans notre hémicycle
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
ministre
en 2003 le pays mesurer la part le poids
et la gravité de l'isolément dans la
surmortalité de nos anciens il y eut un
plan canicule
en 2020 la pandémie induit des mesures
drastiques de sécurité sanitaire nos
aînés sont où qu'ils soient isolés et je
dirais même mis sous cloche
il était impératif de les protéger comme
les soignants d'un virus pernicieux mais
convenait-il de le faire au détriment de
toute humanité
au point d'oublier les enseignements de
2003 dans les structures médico sociales
dès le 7 mars il n'y a plus ni visite ni
journaux ni vivres ni animation partager
unis repas en commun l'art la kiné
réduite les vêtements personnels parfois
août et reste le téléphone pour qu'il
n'est pas sourd et skype
si les du personnel pour assurer les
liaisons en ville
l'aide à domicile se centre sur les plus
dépendants pour les autres la solitude
devient abandon plus d'une ménagère de
visite de kiné les accueils de jour sont
fermées tout s'arrête
les repas sont déposés sur le seuil de
la porte tous les personnels ont fait le
maximum pour que en l'absence des
familles nos anciens soient entourées
sans protection d'abord car oubliés du
système et sont les nécessaires renforts
de personnel le coût humain et nous
pour priver sans le comprendre de la
présence de leurs proches
certains se sont laissés mourir de
chagrin et d'ennui d'autres ont des
pertes irréversible d'autonomie perte de
la motricité faute d'entraînement
physique de la mémoire foot de repères
et de stimulation de vieux couples ont
attendu trois mois pour se voir des
familles ont eu la douleur d'enterrer
leurs morts à la sauvette sans un
dernier regard
monsieur le ministre envisagez-vous
d'établir pour l'avenir un plan pandémie
qui prennent mieux en compte les aînés à
leurs proches je vous remercie pour vous
répondre à la parole que la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice les
personnes âgées constituent un public
particulièrement fragile et vulnérable
et cela a été renforcé pendant la crise
l'âge est un facteur aggravant face au
virus en france plus de 9 personnes sur
10 des cd du coc vides sont âgées de
plus de 65 ans il était une nécessité de
notre notre responsabilité de protéger
nos personnes les plus âgées de leur
permettre d'être à domicile pour celle
qui t'a domicile pour celle qui était à
domicile nous avons enclenché le plan
justement des registres tels qu'ils
avaient été créé suite à la canicule
2003 dont vous faites référence portés
par les communes les associations et sur
lequel nous avons même été plus loin à
ce que les croizier les fichiers soient
croisés avec les données des
départements notamment pour les
bénéficiaires de l'apa et de la pch pour
qu'on aille chercher les personnes les
plus isolées que certaines mairies ne
pouvait pas connaître
nous avons renforcé le numéro vert de la
croix rouge justement à destination des
personnes isolées âgées chez elles pour
que cet isolement et cette rupture de
soi ce soit le plus simple possible et
se laisse moins de traces possibles nous
avons engagé
trente mille jeunes en service civique à
destination des personnes en
établissement en ehpad à destination des
personnes dans les foyers résidences et
dans les aides à domicile
au même titre que trois cent mille
bénévoles se sont mobilisés sur la plate
forme je veux aider point gouv.fr alors
nous dire que nous avons rien fait je ne
peux pas vous laisser dire par contre
oui nous avons été obligés de prendre
des décisions difficiles à prendre quand
il a fallu isoler les personnes en
établissement c'était pour les protéger
nous avons donné des recommandations au
niveau
unal chaque établissement à adapter les
recommandations sanitaires avec un
travail de concertation avec les équipes
soignantes pour adapter en fonction des
besoins et adapté par rapport à chaque
patient et chaque personne si elle était
atteinte ou non du cosy donc nous avons
mises en oeuvre les établissements ont
adapté l'objectif c'est bien d'apporter
une réponse circonstanciée aux éléments
circonstancié tout en étant tout en
ayant le souci de protéger nos puits et
nos plus jeunes aux plus âgés
je vous remercie je leur avec quelques
secondes pour autant madame la ministre
ce que j'ai décrit et du vécu et de
l'observation de terrain au moins dans
mon territoire et je dirais que s'il y
avait eu davantage de pertes de
d'équipements de protection
sans doute qu'on devrait faire beau
parent donc on aurait pu faire beaucoup
mieux avec les bénévoles dont vous
parlez merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue jean
louis masson sénateur n'appartenant à
aucun groupe make ma question et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre le report des
élections régionales est à l'ordre du
jour par contre on parle assez peu des
élections départementales
or afin de lutter contre l'abstention un
consensus se dégage et s'est dégagée
depuis de nombreuses années pour
regrouper les élections locales
ce fut d'ailleurs l'objet de la loi de
monsieur le ministre dans ces conditions
l'éventuel report des élections
régionales seraient serait-il couplé
avec un report identique des élections
départementales l'intérieur répond
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs le sénateur monsieur le
sénateur masson votre question et
précise elle s'appuie sur deux fait un
fait lié à la situation économique et
sociale de notre pays à la suite de la
gestion de la crise du coc vie de 19 qui
se poursuit et un fait institutionnels
dont la gestion territoriale a montrée
peut-être aussi tout l'efficience le
fait politique
vous le connaissez c'est celui
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte que toute
la france soit totalement tournés vers
un seul objectif celui de la
reconstruction économique et social de
notre pays celui de pouvoir s'appuyer
sur des collectivités territoriales
puissante notamment pour construire la
reconstruction économique
à partir de là se pose aussi un deuxième
enseignement de la crise que nous avons
connue la nécessité d'avoir des
collectivités locales puissante des
régions puis sont des départements
qu'ils puissent se mobiliser aussi dans
l'accompagnement social dont chacune et
chacun a besoin sur les territoires
c'est la raison pour laquelle une
réflexion et je dis bien une réflexion
att a été engagée sur cette ambition que
nous devons construire tous ensemble y
compris avec les sénateurs évidemment
pour se projeter vers l'avenir d'une
réorganisation institutionnelle dont
notre pays a besoin mais votre question
de celles sénateurs est très précise si
dia et s'il y avait une décision est
donc une loi qui prévoit parce
qu'évidemment ce serait une loi qui
devra le prévoir qui prévoit après les
discussions avec l'ensemble des acteurs
le report des élections régionales se
posera légitimement la question des
élections départementales parce
qu'aujourd'hui les deux sont liés vous
l'avez rappelé aujourd'hui il est prévu
que la concomitance est la règle et donc
il appartiendra évidemment au
législateur si la question se pose de
prendre la décision de lier ou de délier
ces deux élections monsieur maintenant
il vous reste un peu de temps
ministre il y a il y a quelques mois
nous avons voté une proposition de loi
émanant des parlementaires de la
majorité de votre majorité
selon laquelle on ne doit pas modifier
les modalités d'un scrutin moins d'un an
avant l'élection
or on est en plein en contradiction avec
ce que nous avons voté à la demande sur
proposition d'un parlementaire de votre
majorité
moi je crois que c'est quand même
quelque chose de tout à fait regrettable
que finalement on nous fasse voter des
lois et que cette loi votée par tout le
monde
il ya eu une quasi unanimité maintenant
nous dire on s'assied dessus et on n'en
parle même pas je crois que c'est pas
normal monsieur le premier ministre et
je regrette très honnêtement moi je
regrette cette opération qui se fait un
peu à la sauvette et dont on ne comprend
pas très bien la logique parce que on
peut on a pu faire des élections on a pu
faire
on a pu faire des élections municipales
on n'a pas voulu reporter le deuxième
tour et tout d'un coup on veut reporter
des élections alors même que l'épidémie
a tendance à s'éloigner et on peut très
bien gérer c'est arrivé c'est pas
bastien des élections qu'on n'est plus
capable de gérer des les affaires
conclues les affaires des départements
mais si j'aurais avant d'en terminer
avec notre nos questions saluer de
nouvelle collègue madame muriel cabaret
sénatrice de la sarre qui remplace le
prêtre collègue madame graulhet ces
retenues et madame catherine andré
sénatrice de l'ardèche qui remplace
jacques genest
je leur souhaite vraiment la bienvenue
au nom du sénat tout entier je rappelle
le respect des règles sanitaires
il convient de laisser un siège vide
entre deux sièges occupés ou à défaut de
porter un masque
aujourd'hui c'est pas du 100 % nous
aurons nos questions d'actualité le
mercredi 8 juillet à 15 heures
je suspends la science qui sera repris à
16h30 pour l'examen du projet de loi
organique et du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relatives à la
dette sociale et à l'autonomie la séance
est suspendue
monsieur le premier ministre un grand
merci mesdames et messieurs les milices
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui se
termine donc sur ce rappel des règles
sanitaires qui s'est ouverte sur
l'hommage hommage émouvant à patrice
gélard l'ancien sénateur décédé le 25
juin dernier cet homme malicieux et
fidèle à d'ailleurs souligné le premier
ministre d'un philippe qui le connaît
c'est bien sinon on noté lors de cette
séance plusieurs questions à la ministre
elisabeth bornes notamment sur la
convention citoyenne pour le climat ou
encore et bien l'arrêt de fessenheim
mais on retiendra aussi et bien les
champs sur le parquet national financier
avec notamment la question du sarkozyste
historique pierre charon pierre charon
qui est notamment revenu sur l' affaire
des fadettes les fadettes d'avocats de
magistrats qui ont été épluchés par le
parquet national financiers écoutez
pierre charon cette imbrication malsaine
du bnf dans le jeu politique nous a même
valu il y a trois ans une élection
présidentielle insolite où le favori n'a
même pas été qualifié pour le second
tour
à la suite de propos tenus par l'ancien
procureur du bnf
le président de la république a saisi le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
et vous madame avait demandé timidement
un rapport circonstancié sur la nature
précise de l'enquète du bnf
il était temps de saisir l'inspection
générale tout à l'heure de la justice
car c'est l'existence même du bnf qui
pose problème
madame la garde des sceaux quand on dit
vous faire face à cette crise de
confiance de la justice après que le mur
deco ne soit pas suivie par le mur de la
honte est tout de suite et bien la
réaction de nicole belloubet la garde
des sceaux qui est à votre micro
alexandre salle des conférences
effectivement tam nicole belloubet vous
lancez aujourd'hui est bien une enquête
de l'inspection générale de la justice
sur le fonctionnement du parc national
financiers dans l' affaire dite des
écoutes de nicolas sarkozy le pnf qui a
examiné les revenus à téléphonique d'une
soixantaine d'avocats
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya eu un
dysfonctionnement je ne suis pas capable
de le dire au moment où je vous parle
mais c'est en tout cas la raison pour
laquelle nous avons souhaité diligenter
cette inspection générale de la justice
l'idée c'est évidemment que l'inspection
disposent de quelques semaines à la fois
pour voir quelle est l'étendue et la
proportionnalité également des
investigations qui ont été effectués
celle que vous relevez c'est à dire les
relevés téléphoniques d'un certain
nombre d'avocats de magistrats également
et puis également qu'elle était le cadre
procédural de l'enquète qui a alors été
conduite je ne suis pas au moment où je
vous parle en mesure de dire s'il ya eu
ou non des dysfonctionnements et
pourtant cette inspection à l'est basé
sur un rapport que vous avez demandé au
parquet général de paris
c'est là qu'est ce que dit ce rapport il
ya eu quand même des erreurs de
procédure
ce rapport ne mentionne pas d'erreurs de
procédure ce rapport mentionne un
certain nombre d'éléments factuels sur
la base desquelles j'ai souhaité
diligenter une enquête et est ce que le
parquet national financier à cacher
cette enquête à la défense annonçait
fleury franchement je ne tiens pas de
tels propos parce que c'est vraiment ni
le moment
et ce non pas ce que dit l'opposition
mais l'opposition
2 sur ce sujet là l'opposition conduit
des amalgames qui sont tout à fait
regrettable parce que je crois que dans
notre pays pour tous les citoyens pour
la république il faut avoir confiance
dans la justice s'il y a des
dysfonctionnements éventuels
ils seront reconnus mais il ne faut pas
présupposer qu'il y a eu de tels
dysfonctionnements
franchement les magistrats il y en a
huit mille plus de 8000 en france rands
3 millions décision par an j'ai
confiance dans la justice présomption de
confiance en la justice
absolument la justice donc si jamais il
ya des dysfonctionnements quelles
pourraient être les décisions alors il
ya plusieurs solutions tout dépend de la
nature des dysfonctionnements qui
pourraient être relevées soit ce sont
des évolutions normatives qui passerait
par des dispositions législatives ou
réglementaires pour améliorer le
fonctionnement du parc national
financiers ou de la procédure soit ce
sont des dispositions disciplinaires si
cela apparaît nécessaire mais si c'est
le cas alors le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature sera saisie alors justement
ont vu de toutes ces affaires en de
liens politiques entre avec le parti
national financier la sphère fillon la
sphère va de nicolas sarkozy l' affaire
qui concerne alexis colère est ce qu'il
n'ya pas à un problème de lien
hiérarchique trop fort entre le parquet
général et le pnf moi je dis clairement
que la structuration du parquet en
france répond à une logique
institutionnelle
je le dis je le répète le gouvernement
est responsable devant le parlement qui
effectuent un travail de contrôle
politique et parce que le gouvernement
est responsable devant le parlement de
la politique qu'il conduit
je dois être en mesure de déterminer une
politique pénale générale applicable sur
l'ensemble du territoire est appliquée
avec le travail des procureurs généraux
et des procureurs de la république c'est
pour cela que je peux leur donner des
instructions générales mais jamais
jamais d'instructions particulières dans
des affaires particulières et pour
terminer emmanuel macron avait quand
même promis dès 2017 une réforme pour
plus d'indépendance du parquet où en est
on dans cette réforme bien vous devez le
savoir puisque le projet de révision
constitutionnelle qui a été déposée qui
est déposé au parlement en ce moment
prévoit cette réforme constitutionnelle
allant vers plus d'indépendance
statutaire des magistrats du parquet
c'est à dire une nomination sur avis
forme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et le pouvoir disciplinaire
entièrement donnée au csm
donc cette révision constitutionnelle
nous voulons la faire nous voulons
aboutir et je suis sûr qu'elle sera mené
à terme avant 2022
très bien merci beaucoup nicole
belloubet d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
interview chaque oeil sur ce plateau
pour le débrief des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement dominique
estrosi sassone bonjour jour deux
sénatrices et l'ère des alpes-maritimes
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques et également sur ce plateau
eric kerrouche vous êtes sénateur
socialiste des landes et membre de la
commission des lois
il y à des amalgames regrettable de la
part de l'opposition a dit tout à
l'heure nicole belloubet il faut dire
que le parquet national financiers
beaucoup attaqué notamment par la droite
qu'est ce que vous répondez à la
ministre dominique estrosi sassone non
j'ai entendu que la ministre a parlé
aussi de responsabilité a parlé d'un
mâle gamme regrettable mais aussi de
responsabilité
eh bien je lui répond qu'effectivement
chacun à la place qui est la sienne dans
la société est responsable et que tout
pouvoir est responsable et que donc ne
pouvoir judiciaire est lui aussi
responsable et qu'il n'a pas à s'écarter
de la responsabilité
moi ce que je constate c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la ministre la garde des
sceaux soutien quand même très
timidement le parquet national financier
et que dans la sphère des écoutes
téléphoniques
on peut véritablement s'interroger sur
un certain acharnement qui a pesé pour
prouver à tout prix que le présent à
pully nicolas sarkozy était coupable
alors moi je ne mets pas en cause
l'indépendance de la justice
mais je mets plus tôt mais j'avais cette
rue du parc 1 qui pose problème je pense
plutôt à une impartialité de la justice
qui concilie conduit dans certaines
affaires à une véritable politisation
une trop grande politisation estime
dominique estrosi sassone des magistrats
c'est ça que vous nous dites est ce que
c'est le cas on a entendu aussi et bien
pierre charon qui a fait référence aux
murs des cons du syndicat de la
magistrature on a compris ce qu'il
voulait dire avec sa question tout à
l'heure lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement eric kerrouche oui alors
pressé pas parce qu'il ya eu des
affaires malheureuse qui ont qui ont
existé qui se sont soldées pour
certaines je pense à françois fillon a
à des condamnations que pour autant il
faut remettre en cause l'intégralité du
fonctionnement de la justice
maintenant sur ce point en particulier
les juges ont leur pouvoir tout leur
pouvoir rien que leur pouvoir est en
effet il faut vérifier que celui ci
j'avais dire se déroule dans de bonnes
conditions c'est aussi simple que ça
après on peut pas préjuger non plus de
la qualité du parquet national
financiers je rappelle que quand il a
été créé si on analyse dans le sillon de
la sphère dans le sillon de la sphère
cahuzac
il avait aussi le pnf comme la haute
autorité sur la transparence de la vie
politique dans le sens justement d'une
meilleure transparence d'une plus grande
compréhension par les français des
mécanismes de fonctionnement du pouvoir
donc je pense aussi que la transparence
est nécessaire
donc on verra bien ce qu'il en est des
du traitement de ce sujet en particulier
et tout de suite on va rejoindre pour
une autre réaction hervé marseille qui
est au micro d'alexandre pousseur salle
des conférences toujours et bien sûr et
bien cette affaire sur le parquet
national financiers et oui avec
marseille certains sénateurs de droite
dénoncent l'instrumentalisation
politique de ce parc national financier
est ce que vous êtes d'accord
écoutez il ya des choses troublantes
quand madame houlette
qui était la patronne du ps aujourd'hui
en retraite
c'est clairement voilà sous serment
devant une commission denquête à
l'assemblée nationale dit qu'elle a subi
des pressions
et pas n'importe quoi c'est une femme
qui est magistrat qui parle sous serment
c'est ce qu'elle dit et elle sait où
elle le dit quand on apprend par la
presse
le point en l'occurrence que des écoutes
sont diligentées égard deux membres
éminents du monde des avocats sont
écoutés dans des procédures avec leurs
clients à la recherche soit disant d'une
taupe et
en dehors de procédure extrêmement
préoccupante
il ya de quoi s'inquiéter je dis que
c'est parquet qui sont débarqués
spéciaux deviennent des parcs et
d'exception et on se demande comment ils
sont contrôlés et comment ça fonctionne
donc j'observe que le président de la
république a saisi le csm
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
mais c'est inquiétant parce que le csm
il est saisi de nombreux soit il ya que
2 % de suite à sa saisine et quant à
madame bello b vient enfin de diligenter
une enquête
donc ça veut dire quand même qu'à ses
yeux il se passe quelque chose donc pour
vous le gouvernement est assez réactif
sur et bien le fonctionnement de ce pnf
et les enquêtes autour il aura fallu
attendre qu'ils aient des révélations et
par madame houlette et par la presse
sinon on aurait pas aujourd'hui la
réaction du garde des sceaux est ce
qu'il faudrait supprimer ce parc
national financiers ou alors le réformer
le rendre plus indépendant à l'évidence
il ya un problème avec le monde
judiciaire et notamment avec le pnf et
je pense que ça mériterait un débat est
sûrement une réforme qu'on intègre ray
par exemple dans une révision de la
constitution sur l'indépendance du
parquet de manière générale pas ça fait
partie des projets qui avait déjà été
étudiées il ya quelques mois quand on
parlait d'une révision de la
constitution
en tout état de cause on va attendre les
résultats de ces interrogations de ses
enquêtes et je pense qu'il faudra que on
a au moins vers un début de réforme très
bien merci beaucoup si hervé marseille
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre dominique
estrosi sassone est ce que à l'instar
d'eric ciotti vous vous demander la
suppression du parquet national
financiers ou simplement une réforme non
je pense qu'il faut effectivement se
poser la question sur la suppression du
parquet national financier mais je pense
que ça ne suffit pas et que derrière la
grande question est celle de la réforme
de la justice
on le voit bien sur la question des
recrutements sur la question des
carrières des magistrats mais aussi sur
la question de la responsabilité j'y
reviens des magistrats dans le cadre des
procédures tant que toutes ces questions
ne sont pas directement posé sur la
table si j'ose dire j'ai que les
magistrats sont de parti pris parfois
c'est ça que vous
je pense qu'en tout cas on ne peut pas
le balayer d'un revers de la main et que
force est de constater qu'on peut sur
certaines affaires être amené à se poser
ces questions éric kerrouche qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce que vient de dire
dominique estrosi sassone et est ce que
pour vous à la suppression du parc
national financiers se pose je pense
qu'on peut pas préjuger de la qualité du
pnr en fonction du camp auquel on
appartient politiquement mais pour
parler concrètement je crois qu'il ya
une attaque de la droite et une défense
de la gauche en ce moment oui enfin ce
il a plu je pense encore une fois que la
création de cette institution était
nécessaire et qu'elle fait partie des
institutions qui permettent de rendre
confiance notamment dans la vie
politique et qu'il ne faut pas qu'il ne
faut pas les rejeter
maintenant et là je suis partiellement
en accord avec vous cela ne veut pas
dire que le pnf doit déborder des
compétences qui sont les siennes
tous les pouvoirs sont encadrés y
compris le pouvoir judiciaire
allez on va passer à un autre sujet qui
a largement marqué cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
et bien double actualité sur la question
de l'environnement
avec tout d'abord et bien l'arrêt de la
centrale de fessenheim est ce que qu'est
ce que vous pensez de l'arrêt de cette
centrale
on a entendu elisabeth bande défendre le
fait que ce n'était pas de l'idéologie
et défendre un système électrique
diversifié on a du mal à le croire
moi je pense sincèrement que l'arrêt de
la centrale de fessenheim porte atteinte
aux intérêts de notre pays
elle portait aussi atteinte à un
territoire c'est l'état qui abandonne un
territoire entier on a fait référence
plus de 2000 emplois directs et
indirects une économie qui est forcément
fragilisé de l'immobilier des commerces
et l'état en conséquence prévoit 7 20
ans entame de fermeture mais ne prévoit
aucune mesure de rebond immédiate totale
eh bien il faut bien continuer à
produire l'électricité est aujourd'hui
même si on veut se positionner dans un
mix énergétique qui prendrait de
l'éolien du solaire on sait très bien
que c'est un avenir quand même dominique
wisler très bien que l'essentiel de
l'électricité pour l'heure continuera à
être produite par des chants trad
centrales à gaz et à charbon et qu'elles
émettent énormément de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère et que
finalement l'arrêt de fessenheim ses 2.5
millions de tonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère chaque année donc où est la
rationalité d'une telle décision quand
en plus on entend l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui dit que la centrale de
fessenheim était une des plus anciennes
mais l'une des plus sûres et que je le
rappelle l'énergie nucléaire est une
énergie décarbonée une énergie
décarbonée héritiers rochas que c'est un
argument que vous entendez une énergie
décarbonée certes mais une énergie
risqués et personne ne peut le nier
on peut pas faire comme s'il n'y avait
aucun risque avec avec le nucléaire et
la question des déchets aussi et la
question des déchets et surtout de leur
traitement et de leur stockage qui nous
pose des difficultés parce qu'en fait il
ya assez peu assez peu de candidats pour
l'accueil juste un point de de
convergence avec vous c'est plutôt ça
qui me dérange moi c'est le non
traitement par l'état de ce territoire
la centrale en tant que tel on peut
avoir des oppositions moi je pense qu'on
n'ira de toute façon progressivement
vers un abandon parce que nos centrales
vieillissent et vous savez également
comme moi que le coût de fonctionnement
de ses centrales
le coût de maintenance est extrêmement
important est qu'on ne peut pas exclure
encore une fois les risques et puis les
risques d'approvisionnement en uranium
qu'il est difficile de sécuriser
étant donné leurs origines une fois
qu'on a dit ça la vraie difficulté c'est
simplement que il aurait fallu bien
entendu avec cette fermeture que l'on
ait un accompagnement fort de l'état
parce que quand on est en situation de
monopole tivité quand on dépend
énormément de cette activité
alors si on prend une telle décision
politique il faut en assumer les
responsabilités moi ce qui me dérange
c'est ça c'est la non prise de
responsabilités à la hauteur de ce que
ça mais c'est de ce que ça nécessiterait
sur ce territoire
donc critique sur le territoire la
droite a donc été très favorable à la
convenance à la centrale de fessenheim
vous avez aussi beaucoup critiqué la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
dernièrement
est-ce que vous maintenez aujourd'hui
ces critiques quand vous voyez est bien
cette vague verte qui montre aujourd'hui
l'importance des questions environ
mental pour les français c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle fessenheim c'est un
symbole pour les français mais je crois
qu'il faut pas tout mélanger
cette vague verte puisque vous l'appelez
ainsi il faudrait vraiment l'analyse est
une façon beaucoup plus poussée c'est
aussi une vague qui vient des
territoires et des territoires dans ces
territoires là on construit une écologie
ont construit une écologique et
constructives ont construit une écologie
qui innovantes
je vois à nice la smart cities
l'économie circulaire donc ça fait
partie de cette écologie qui vient des
territoires moi ce que je vois c'est que
en opposition il ya une écologie qui est
une écologie dogmatique une écologie
politique ni cologie idée idéologique
qui prône à tout prix la décroissance et
là dessus je pense qu'effectivement moi
je n'adhère pas à ce type d'écologie je
pense que c'est beaucoup plus à partir
des territoires
quant à la convention citoyenne les
propositions qui sont faites on verra
bien le prénom la république a fait un
grand barnum pour dire on va les mettre
en application
bon il n'ya pas des choses non plus
qu'ils sont totalement innovante laon
score au regard de ce qu'on fait déjà
dans les territoires il y a un coût
alors on nous a annoncé 15 milliards
d'euros
ça c'est aussi dans un période avec des
comptes publics qui sont quand même très
fragilisé réinvesti personne aussi c'est
de l'investissement qu'à venir mais je
pense que tout remettre entre les mains
de 150 personnes quand on fait porter
cela au niveau national moi je suis pour
la démocratie participative mais au
niveau local mais dès que c'est porter
au niveau national je veux dire que
représente 150 citoyens avec toute la
bonne volonté qui est la leur à
l'échelle d'un pays de 65 millions
d'habitants
je pense que cette démocratie à travers
ce tirage au sort c'est un peu une
démocratie du hasard vous remettez en
cause le tirage au sort la légitimité de
la convention citoyenne et ricky rouge
qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous pensez vous
au contraire est bien de de ce que ce
travail effectué par an à ses 150
citoyens et qui emmanuel macron a promis
de traduire en majorité en décret en loi
voire en référendum
on oublie pendant longtemps que le
tirage au sort était la règle de la
démocratie et l'élection s'était plutôt
l'exception
ça s'est inversé ça s'est inversé au
xviiie siècle la phase ultime du xviiie
siècle
c'est pas il n'est pas plus légitime ni
loi illégitime c'est une manière dit
c'est une manière différente de composer
avec la vie avec la vie démocratique
c'est aussi une expérience qu'il faut
savoir mener parce que ce sera une
demande non seulement au niveau
territorial mais je pense au niveau
global
on l'a vu en islande lors de
l'élaboration de la constitution par
exemple
non moi ce qui me gêne c'est pas tant
les propositions que ce qui en est fait
ou dans ce cas là on met une instance
comme la convention et et elle elle
prend des décisions ou elle peut les
mettre en oeuvre
mais en fait là on passe encore une fois
par le filtre du président de la
république qui ne reprend pas
l'intégralité de ce qu'il avait promis
de faire et si c'est un outil ou un
instrument ou un jeu à quoi ça sert en
tout cas et bien l'exécutif a montré une
attention à cette convention qui était
d'autant plus importante que il ya eu
les élections municipales auparavant ces
élections muncipales y en a été question
lors des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement je vous propose d'écouter
tout à l'heure l'intervention de
laurence rossignol donc à quelques étés
sont prêts la majorité ne conquiert
aucune ville importante et même mêmes
pères des villes qu'elle avait obtenu
auparavant grâce à des transfuges
souvent d'ailleurs de nos propres rangs
je pense à lyon je pense à besançon je
pense à strasbourg et même dans mon
département c'est arrivé et sans parler
bien sûr des échecs de vos ministres qui
comptait bien faire main basse sur la
ville de paris et qui chacun le sait ont
aussi échoué
oui dominique estrosi sassone un mot de
ces élections municipales
quels enseignements en tirez-vous et est
ce que la droite a des difficultés avec
les centres urbains avec les grandes
villes certes vous avez remporté nice
mais il ya tout de même eu les problèmes
sur bordeaux perpignan nancy qui
basculent à gauche est ce qu'il ya un
électorat reconquérir pour vous alors je
pense que bien évidemment au vu du taux
d'abstention il ya forcément un
électorat reconquérir mais pour
l'ensemble de la classe politique
après je ne veux pas opposer la france
des territoires ruraux à la france des
métropoles où est la france urbaine je
pense que on est là pour parler à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
c'est vrai qu'on a plutôt engranger des
10 des résultats positifs dans les
villes moyennes dans les territoires
ruraux
mais dans certaines métropoles là où
nous avons perdu pourquoi nous avons
perdu parce qu'ils lui il ya eu ces
alliances de second tour qui ont été des
alliances purement politiciennes vous
voulez dire hé bé oui et donc ça ne va
le tirer vers le fond et forcément ça
n'a pas plu aux électeurs ce que je peux
très bien le comprendre
lorsqu'il n'y a pas eu ces alliances
quand bien même il y avait un large
rassemblement au premier tour eh bien on
a gagné donc il faut vraiment être clair
de plus en plus clair vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens ou au contraire à gauche
sans les alliances qui vous ont réussi
c'est le retour de la gauche plurielle
il faut en tout cas aujourd'hui faire
avec les écologistes pour la gauche
c'est le retour simplement d'un bloc de
gauche sociale et écologique comme il le
devrait être et quand on s'entend nous
arrivons à avoir des résultats
quant à la république en marche est un
parti qui a été fondée sur
l'opportunisme et sur le retournement de
veste bien il savait il s'avère que ça
ne paye pas toujours on l'a vu on l'a vu
dimanche dernier
ça ne paye pas très loin non vraiment en
quelques secondes sur le fait que demain
gérard larcher présente les propositions
du sénat en matière est bien de libertés
locales c'est ce qui ressort pour vous
de bien c'est après crise du coc vide
je pense que on ne pourra pas faire sans
une nouvelle décentralisation en france
c'est la décentralisation qui va
désormais structuré la france plus
l'état central la décentralisation
emmanuel macron en a parlé dans l'un de
ses discours post cowitz est un bon
signal pour vous sur les coudes
peut-être des territoires dominique
estrosi sassone pour signaler les
propositions qui seront faites demain
par le groupe qui a été mise en place
par gérard larcher parce qu'il faut
donner effectivement plus de libertés
locales aux collectivités territoriales
voilà pour le teasing de cette
conférence de presse qui a donc lieu
demain au sénat et que vous pourrez
suivre
il ya en direct sur public sénat à
partir de 10h30
je vous laisse car et d'un il ya aussi
les auditions à l'assemblée nationale
dans le cadre de la commission d'
enquête sur la gestion du coc vide
et puis à 22h ne manquez pas non plus
loin avec rebecca fitoussi qui elle vous
parlera de la réouverture des frontières
européennes
la très bonne soirée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]